Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin, ich bin auch wieder da.
Mir ging es die letzten Wochen nicht so gut.
Keinen Bock zu streamen.
Immer so ein bisschen auf und ab.
Was hat es immer noch das Gleiche,
was ich seit einem jahr habe
schwere bronchitis aha ja und ist wieder besser
hoffe ich mal
so jetzt als erstes ich muss meine vm updaten weil die habe ich schon jetzt
sei den letzten mal streamen das irgendwie drei wochen her oder so nicht mehr geupdatet das heißt
da gibt es jetzt ganz viele packages und dann gibt es eine reboot ob falsch die mode egal
ja ich will mich jetzt auch nicht darüber auslassen das einmal erzählt es reicht oder
Ich habe keinen Bock.
Ist nicht so toll.
So, danke.
So, Chat.
Updates.
Wichtig.
Boah, guck mal hier.
wie viel Packages, Updates.
Total Install
seit 4,7 Gig Updates.
Also quasi ein kleiner Patch
für Windows.
Max, hast du die
guten Nachrichten? Was? Was für gute Nachrichten?
Weiß nicht,
gab es irgendwas Tolles?
Außer, dass Microsoft
jetzt Micro Slop genannt wird.
Seit ein paar Wochen.
Ist auch irgendwie eine gute Nachricht.
Weil die gehen mir mit ihrem...
Ach ja, was ist denn da?
Was ist denn mit denen?
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Ach.
Ja, gut.
Mir tut es um die Mitarbeiter leid.
Aber nicht um die Leute,
die diese komische Entscheidung getroffen haben,
Leute die Sicherheitslücken melden,
zu verklagen.
Feiership, ich hab tatsächlich ein Feiership-Video offen, das gucken wir nachher an.
Mittlerweile muss man ja echt sagen, gerade auf Twitter, ich nenne das weiterhin Twitter, ganz ehrlich.
Ich kann nicht nachvollziehen, warum man Twitter jemals unbenannt hat.
Welche Software hat es denn so geschafft wie Twitter, dass sowas wie Tweet und so in den normalen Sprachgebrauch übergeht?
Dann wird es unbenannt, total hängen geblieben.
Ja, auf Twitter muss man echt mittlerweile gucken, da gibt es so viele AI-generated Videos, die aber mittlerweile so echt aussehen, dass du die kaum auseinanderhalten kannst.
So gibt es Videos, Katze springt in Schnee. So, AI-generiert, erkennst du nicht.
Da musst du schon ganz genau hingucken, dass du das erkennst
Weil manchmal so komische Dinge sind wie
Es kommt ja der
Wenn es kalt ist, da gibt es ja immer so
Wie heißt denn das?
Wenn man ausatmet, da kommt immer so eine Wolke
Wenn es kalt ist
Das war ein bisschen an der falschen Stelle
Und zu viel und so
Aber ansonsten, wenn man da nicht drauf achtet, erkennt man nichts
Es gibt jetzt auch Breaking Bad in Deutschland
Äh
Das gab es doch schon die ganze Zeit, auch in Deutschland
Oder meinst du, es gibt jetzt eine deutsche Version davon
Okay, das wird wahrscheinlich schlecht
Ich weiß nicht
So deutsche, also das einzige, was ich mir halbwegs angucken konnte, wobei ich da nach einer Zeit auch keinen Bock mehr hatte, war Dark.
Serie.
Das ging, ja.
Wobei es mir dann irgendwie auch zu lahmarschig geworden ist mit der Zeit.
Aber da war zumindest die erste Staffel war ganz gut.
Ach so, AI, ja gut.
Die Ducca Updates sind fertig was heißt das wenn Updates fertig sind
Es wird Zeit Für. Die momentaner nicht reboot noch nicht reboot
Xz cool not found Jetzt ist es Wieder
Moment Bevor wir reboot Machen noch Die Ganzen our Packages
Aktualisieren und Jet Brains
update.
WTF, gibt es hier alles
Update, außer für Ryder. Für Ryder gibt es keine Update.
Na gut. Session has expired.
Das sagt, muss ich wieder einloggen.
So, jetzt ist das dauert jetzt, bis wir hier Updates
gemacht haben.
Und sag ich's.
Also schon mal in Juni von JetBrains getestet.
Ich habe das mal kurz gestartet, weil ich habe da ein paar Tokens für.
Wenn man dieses Premium-Desktop-Pack oder wie das heißt bei JetBrains, gibt es ein paar JetBrains-AI-Talks mit drin.
Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde das übelst reudig, die Integration von AI-Sachen in die JetBrains-ID.
Das ruckelt as fuck.
Selbst die Formatierung im Chat ist kaputt.
Also, das habe ich ganz schnell wieder weggeschmissen.
und ich benutze jetzt für Kommandozeilen Kram und so benutze ich OpenCode.
OpenCode ist echt nice.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Vor allem, was man alles kostenlos kriegt.
Man kriegt GPT-5 Nano kostenlos, man kriegt GNM 4.7 kostenlos
und man kriegt Minimax M2.1 kostenlos.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Also für kostenlos, ich meine, das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so gut wie Opus 4.5,
aber es ist für kostenlos echt nicht verkehrt
also ganz ehrlich das ist das die sind bei mir unten durch mit mit
als stells budget also wenn ihr das nicht grundlegend noch mal verbessern
mit der integration dann ist es ist das schrott
übrigens chat ich will mir was kaufen und zwar ich will mir einen new cream was kaufen 4800 plus
das da will ich mir kaufen warum mache ich das eigentlich in dem browser auf und nicht hier
das das will ich mir kaufen das ist teurer geworden von wegen minus ich habe da vor drei
wochen oder so oder zwei drei wochen schon mal geguckt da war es glaube ich noch ein bisschen
billiger was ist das dafür klopft geht da ok chat stellt aber nicht so ein ding wollte ich
mehr kaufen.
Weil ich finde,
dass das eine ganz gute Kombination
ist,
aus CPU-
Mittlerweile hast du mehr
Pop-Ups als eigentlichen Seiten-Content.
Ja.
Weil ich finde, dass es eine ganz gute Kombination ist,
aus relativ sparsamer CPU,
wobei ich schon gelesen habe, da brauchst du
einige BIOS-Tweaks.
Bin ich eigentlich
der Einzige, der den Kram nicht-
Nicht EFI, oh EFI nennt, sondern immer noch BIOS.
Ähm, du brauchst wohl einige BIOS Tweaks, dass der Stromsparmodus und so richtig klappt, aber man, sollten wir hinkriegen.
Du kriegst eine 10 Gig Netzwerkkarte und ich werde mir dann wahrscheinlich Proxmox draufhauen, einfach mal so ein bisschen rumbasteln und vielleicht löst das ja meine Unraid Kiste ab.
Die Android-Kiste, die tut einfach.
Das ist ein HP-Micro-Server.
Gen, keine Ahnung, 10 oder so.
Der hat aber nur 4 Kerne.
Gut, ich meine, das ist immer noch schneller als das Ding hier mit seinen 5.
Die CPU ist jetzt wirklich nicht die allerschnellste.
Das sind 4 Efficiency-Cores und ein Performance-Core.
Also es hält sich in Grenzen.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass man da einen lokalen AI-Server mitmachen kann oder so.
und man hat auch keine
PCI Express Einschübe. Das hat man nicht.
Aber was man hat, deswegen glaube ich,
das ist echt eine ganz gute Kombination für
so einen Virtualisierungshost, um dann
auch ein bisschen Netzwerk Storage mitzumachen.
Was es hat ist,
du hast vier
3,5 Zoll Einschübe und
du hast unten, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob man das hier irgendwie sieht.
Die wichtigsten
Sachen zeigen es ja wieder nicht.
Du hast drei
NVMe SSDs.
Die schreiben hier nur zwei, aber ich zeige euch mal was. Ich habe mich ja da schon schlau gemacht.
Aber wenn man genau guckt, wenn das Video jetzt lädt, wäre natürlich nice.
Aber...
Das Video hat keinen Bock.
Aus Slack?
Self-Destroyed.
Ja, Slack, weiß ich, ist gar nicht mehr so richtig in Benutzung.
So, was man hier jetzt sieht, ist,
wenn man sich das anguckt, woran den Kram hier aufschaut...
Ah, da war's.
Moment, da war's schon.
Ist blöd.
Chat, ich hatte es eben.
Hier, guck mal.
Das ist das Ding, was normalerweise zugänglich ist.
Da gibt es zwei NVMe-SSDs und halt für RAM.
Aber hier neben ist noch eine interne M.2-SSD.
Also streng genommen hat das Ding drei NVMe-Slots.
Und das ist echt ganz nice.
3 NVMe Slots, 4 3,5 Zoll Wechselrahmen Dinger vorne.
Da könnte man zum Beispiel sowas machen wie hier drauf, also man muss hier die interne auch nicht tauschen.
Das hier ist eine, also was mitgeliefert wird ist eine 128 Gig interne SSD.
Ich nenne die jetzt mal intern, weil man da nicht mit einer Klappe hier dran kommt.
So, und da könnte man beispielsweise hier drauf Proxmox installieren oder Unraid oder was auch immer man verwenden will, Debian, könnte man hier drauf installieren.
Hier könnte man sich einen RAID 1 drauf machen auf die zwei NVMe SSDs für Container und VMs und so Zeug und vielleicht auch als Write Cache fürs NAS.
hier habe ich dann 32 g gramm rein den habe ich noch zum glück den habe ich noch sonst
wird es teuer 32 g gramm wenn man den ich hatte den habe ich noch auch den passenden formfaktor
ich habe hier nämlich so eine mini pc ich habe hier nämlich so mini pc den habe ich vor ein
weiß ich nicht, 1-2 Jahren gekauft, da war RAM noch billig.
Ja, und da habe ich 32 GB drin.
Das heißt, das wird mit 8 GB ausgeliefert, dann baue ich einfach die 8 GB in diesen Mini-PC ein,
falls ich den brauche und hier baue ich die 32 GB aus dem Mini-PC ein.
Und vorne muss ich mal gucken, welche Festplatten ich reinstecke für größere Datenmengen
Und dann muss ja noch eine rein für nächtliches Backup.
Das habe ich mir überlegt.
So, das wollte ich mir kaufen, das Teil.
Und noch was anderes.
Wartet mal.
Ja, doch, passt.
Und noch was anderes.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal...
...dieses Ding hier ausprobiert?
KVMs.
GL irgendwas.
Dieses Teil hier.
Chatgear.
Das finde ich, klingt eigentlich ganz nice.
Das ist eine KVM.
Mit
WiFi.
Also man müsste das Ding gar nicht per
Kabel irgendwie
anstöpseln.
also im Endeffekt holst du dir USB, holst dir Strom von dem USB, stöpselst HDMI dran und gut ist,
sieht aus wie JetKar, JetKar ist ein bisschen kleiner, ja, aber das Teil wollte ich mir auch kaufen und ausprobieren,
das Ding ist nur, dass das bei Amazon total teuer ist, wenn man hier mal im Internet guckt,
Products.
Oder auch nicht.
Wenn man hier mal im Internet guckt,
dann
gibt es das
teilweise billiger.
Shop now.
Okay, ich habe nichts
gesagt.
So viel billiger ist es
gar nicht.
aber immer noch billiger. Mal kurz gucken, ob es das Ding vielleicht in Deutschland auch noch
irgendwie billiger gibt. Ja, ja, geben wir nicht auch einen Keks hier. Nee, gibt es gar nichts hier.
Sind irgendwelche komischen Unterhose. Aber das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Und als SSD werde ich einfach hier Samsung 990 Pro SSDs reinhauen.
Da kaufe ich mir noch eine 1TB Version, weil ich habe noch eine 1TB Version.
Da brauche ich nur eine SSD.
Was kostet der Kram eigentlich mittlerweile?
Ist auch schweineteuer geworden, oder?
990 Pro 1TB.
Nicht, dass ich es mir jetzt nicht leisten kann, aber es ist schon ganz schön teuer.
Gratis-Lieferung bis Mittwoch, okay.
Gibt es das Ding hier eigentlich auch auf Amazon?
4.800 plus.
Ach, gibt es auch bei Amazon, dann kostet es gleich.
Was ist denn das hier?
Ah, das ist wohl die alte Version, hä?
Ist das wohl die alte Version?
Oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist wohl die neue Version.
Aha, okay.
Ah, die heißt ja auch Plus, genau.
Ja, die alte hieß ohne Plus.
Kein Synology, weil Synology komische Dinger machen will.
Ich weiß, das haben die schon wieder abgesagt.
Mit Festplatten, die von ihnen autorisiert wurden.
Und weil Synology ziemlich teuer ist für das, was du an Leistung kriegst.
ich werde da eh selbst was drauf installieren ich werde nicht das os von
denen verwenden
also das heißt dann muss ich erst einmal hier 589 und die 1 terabyte 99 pro 174
gut sind wir einfach mal 800 euro knapp los
da kannst du auch drauf laufen lassen klar was du nicht hast ist du hast kein
intern usb stecker wie der hp microserver der hat so einen internen
usb stecker gerade für solche sachen wie android da muss man den stick nicht
außen dran stecken sondern kann in ihnen quasi aus dem import stecken aber das
ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt egal kannst auch den usb stick draußen dran machen
macht ja keinen Unterschied. Das muss ich rausziehen.
Und das geht einfach. Also
ich weiß es jetzt ja nicht direkt, aber
wenn man, also aus eigener Hand,
aber wenn man auf Reddit guckt,
ist das wohl eines der beliebtesten
so Self-Build-Virtualisierungsplattformen
oder für irgendwelche
Netzwerk-Storages, die es zur Zeit gibt.
Unrate bleibt auch, dass man das OS
auf der F... Ja, endlich! Endlich!
Also an sich finde ich
das gar nicht verkehrt, ja.
das mit dem Android auf den USB-Stick installieren.
Der USB-Stick, der ist ja im Endeffekt
nahezu
write-frei. Da wird er nicht
drauf geschrieben. Das heißt, das Ding, das geht auch nicht
kaputt oder sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass es
kaputt geht.
Aber
Android mit dieser Seriennummer-Geschichte
ist echt ein bisschen ätzend.
Also, dass es beispielsweise
USB-Stick sein muss.
Was spricht gegen eine interne 128-Gig
ssd bei android die hält genauso lang wie der usb stick wenn ich drauf geschrieben wird eher länger
und was da nichts draußen dran rum bammeln
also finde ich nicht verkehrt so jetzt haben wir gehabt
Also ich denke mal, das wird alles so funktionieren.
Aber erst einmal bestellen.
Und wenn dann alles funktioniert, dann noch Festplatten bestellen.
Festplatten werden auch nochmal teuer.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, wie ich es machen werde.
Also, auf Unraid habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr.
Aber vielleicht ist es trotzdem nach wie vor das Beste für so Heimbereich mäßig.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht wird es auch wieder Unraid.
Aber ich werde erstmal testweise Proxmox drauf installieren.
Was ist mit deinem jetzigen Server? Willst du ihn austauschen?
Ja, wenn das gut funktioniert, tausche ich den aus.
Alle paar Jahre mal neue Server-Hardware.
Ist doch nicht verkehrt.
YouTube-Bee.
Ja, stimmt.
Was spricht gegen Trunas?
Dass ich Trunas einmal ausprobiert habe
und es mir nicht gefallen hat.
Spricht dagegen.
Ich frage mich jetzt aber nicht mehr,
was mir genau nicht gefallen hat.
Das war mir zu lange her. Ich habe mir nur gemerkt,
dass es mir nicht gefallen hat.
So, rebooted haben wir.
Sehr schön.
Exzellent.
Foxbox habe ich halt
keine Ahnung von. Da muss ich mir mal ein bisschen
reinwurschteln.
Dann.
Von der Idee her.
wie ist denn so virtualisierung auf tuners und und container kram das letzte
mal wo ich tun als ausprobiert habe war das so ein komisches lokal installiertes
kubernetes für container ganz wir
läuft mittlerweile mit okay das ist aber nicht verkehrt
Okay, das ist gut.
Das Tunas damals, was wir ausprobiert haben, das war auch schon auf Linux-Basis.
Das war kein BSD mehr.
Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Aber einfach irgendwelche Skripte copy-pasten, weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine, die meisten Sachen, die man da drüber installieren kann, kann ich auch selbst von Hand installieren.
Ich bin ja da nicht ganz unfähig, was solche Linux-Sachen angeht.
Okay, meint ihr,
Trunas ist mal wieder...
Aber ganz ehrlich,
VM und Containerverwaltung dürften doch
mit Proxmox deutlich besser sein
als mit Trunas.
Wobei Proxmox
ja immer noch keine Docker-Container kann.
Die haben ja nur so einen halbherzigen
Workaround
mit Docker-Containern,
der mir nicht gefällt.
Die wandeln Docker-Container um
in LXC-Images
quasi und starten das dann.
Viele machen auch Tunas in Proxmox.
Da weiß ich nicht.
Ich wollte mal Open Media Vault wieder ausprobieren,
weil das schön leichtgewichtig war das letzte Mal,
wo ich es getestet habe.
Ich würde das ja nur für
Summershares im Endeffekt benutzen,
weil ich immer unfähig bin, mich dran zu erinnern,
wie die Summerconfig richtig funktioniert.
Also vielleicht werde ich das...
Mal gucken.
Also was ich mir schon überlegt habe, was man machen könnte, ist...
Man baut sich hier in die Kiste...
Ich mache jetzt nochmal auf, dass die Leute wissen, wovon ich spreche.
Ne, ne, nicht das Minis-Forum.
Genau, das Ding.
Also was man theoretisch machen könnte, was ich mir schon überlegt habe, ist...
Man würde da beispielsweise Proxmox drauf installieren.
Da...
Mit ZFS.
BlackHD, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellent. Wie geht's dir?
Mir ging's die letzten Wochen nicht so gut.
Wegen der Geschichte, die ich ja schon mal erzählt hab.
Aber gerade ist es ein bisschen besser.
Also, was ich mir überlegt hab,
was man machen könnte.
Oh, da ist sogar das Flagship nass.
Wahrscheinlich steht das bei jedem ihrer Nasses dran.
Die haben doch immer nur ein Nass mit jeweils
so und so viel Base, oder?
Flagship, ey. Gut, egal.
Was ich sagen wollte. Was man machen könnte ist, was ich mir überlegt habe. Man installiert da Proxmox drauf mit ZFS. Dann macht man ein ZFS Mirror auf die zwei NVMe SSDs für Container und VMs.
äh, TS-Fuchs, das würde mich tatsächlich auch interessieren, falls jemand das schon verwendet, genau, ähm, Mirror, ZFS-Mirror machen auf die SSDs, dann mal gucken, wie schnell das ist, aber das Ding dürfte eigentlich leistungsmäßig genug haben, hat Hardware-Encryption in der CPU, also, äh, ZFS-Mirror und da drauf ein Dataset mit Encryption, mit ZFS-Encryption, also es dürfte dafür eigentlich ohne Probleme schnell genug sein,
gerade weil man hardware encryption der cpu hat sollte das jetzt nicht großartig probleme machen
ich denke da kriegt man ordentliche ssd speeds hin also das ding nicht hat ist etc ram aber man
braucht für zfs auch nicht zwangsläufig etc ram ich weiß dass es wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder da
das free nas forum ist am ragen wenn ich das sag das free das forum ist nach dem microcontroller
forum so ziemlich das schlimmste was ich kenne alle gibt es also gibt es das überhaupt noch
primers forum alles das heißt jetzt das heißt jetzt schulers forum schulers community ja
kennt ihr das kennt noch immer das frieders forum die hat also dinge erzählt wie du musst
etc ram verwenden ansonsten implodiert ein server so nach dem motto oder oder oder auch
ein gigabyte ram pro was war's ein gigabyte ram pro terabyte speicher irgendwie sowas
ich weiß das ist wenn man das im enterprise umfeld mit vielen leuten die darauf zukauft
einsetzen will meinetwegen würde heim ist das kein ding und es geht auch nicht kaputt ohne etc ram
zf es macht schon mehr als die meisten anderen fall systeme was mit checksum und so angeht also
das ist nicht unsicher als abfallsysteme zumindest hat das wurde das früher immer
so geschrieben als wäre es das ist es aber nicht
ECC RAM ist so keine Ahnung
wenn du
kann man sagen
wenn das quasi so on the fly
irgendwelche
Daten
sind während der
Übertragung
vom RAM auf die
von einem Prozess zum anderen über den
RAM und dann auf die
Disk da könnte man das dabei feststellen
mit ECC-RAM.
Wieso Samsung keine
wie die Red?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja gut, weil ich schon...
Ich hab ja eine 990 Pro noch übrig.
Also
BitRod kenn ich nur in Form von
so persistente Sachen auf irgendwelchen
DIVs oder SSDs.
Selbst da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen. Aber das
stellt ZFS zumindest durch die ganzen
Checksummen ganz gut fest. Zumindest war ich jetzt eigentlich
sagen würde. Also,
ZFS Mirror auf die zwei SSDs,
die sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen hier nicht
drin haben. Verstehe ich. Ich verstehe gar nicht,
warum die nicht ein Bild von unten zeigen.
GachiBuzz.
Wo man das mit den SSDs
sieht, weil ich habe es euch ja gerade gezeigt.
Kannst nämlich hier unten
hier unten
auf der anderen Seite kannst du
SSDs reinstopseln. Ach ja, und was ich auch
ganz cool finde das Ding hat einen SD-Karten-Slot.
Nicht, dass ich ihn brauchen würde,
aber warum nicht?
Du hast ein Debian Unstable
mit ZFS 2.4.
Gibt es irgendwas Tolles in ZFS 2.4?
Warum du das
gemacht hast? Oder einfach nur just for fun zum
Basteln? Zumindest was ich sagen wollte jetzt,
um das mal zu Ende zu bringen. Also,
ein ZFS Mirror
auf die zwei internen
SSDs.
Die zwei internen NVMe
SSDs. Und dann
könnte man, mal gucken,
wie das funktioniert. Wollen wir mal schauen.
Dann könnte man
beispielsweise
Open Media Vault
vor allem installieren. Also, es gibt zwei
Möglichkeiten. Man könnte es, sag ich mal,
lightweight
machen.
Man startet einen LXC-Container,
installiert sich ein
drauf und gut ist könnte man machen man könnte sich man könnte aber auch mal ausprobieren wie
das leistungstechnisch aussieht wenn man einen media wall zum beispiel ich nehme jetzt mal
exemplarisch könnte auch andrej tuners oder whatever sein in der vm installiert und sich
das durchreicht mit durchreichen meine ich jetzt nicht die ssds selber sondern das zfs würde ich
schon über Proxmox machen, sondern quasi ein Verzeichnis vom Host an die VM durchreichen.
Das geht in der Tat mittlerweile ganz gut.
Da gibt es VirtioFS.
Da kann man Ordner vom Host in die VM mappen.
Und das wohl auch relativ schnell.
Ob das schnell genug für 10 GB ist, muss man mal sehen.
Müsste es aber eigentlich.
Das Ding hat ja jetzt nicht so eine Kack-CPU.
ist jetzt nicht die performance monster aber sie geht in ordnung so und dann könnte man sich dann
ein ordner durchreichen und dann könnte man seine samba shares und gedöns über media volt machen
bloß vielleicht um andere sachen mal gucken wie gut das funktioniert weil ich meine dann hatte
man dann hätte man immerhin das wäre ein paar abstraktions ebene ja man hätte unten seine ssd
da hatte man zf smiro da drauf und data set mit cfs encryption dann wird die
ofs in die vm weiterreichen darüber noch mal einen sammler wo man
darauf zugreifen über das netzwerk ob das uns mittlerweile geht ja
verzeichnis durch reichen was deutlich besser als früher mit kvm
vielleicht könnte man auch noch ein merger fs dazwischen hängen
das müssen wir mal ausprobieren dass man den ssd cache baut also sprich dass man
seine festplatte mounted in den open media wollt seine seine ssds mounted in
den open media wollt und dann mercer fs darüber macht und einfach sagt neue
dateien immer auf dem ssd erstellen immer auf den ssds erstellen und man
muss die dann einmal am tag rüber auf die hdd aber gucken ob das funktioniert
ist ja schon ganz schön viele schichten übereinander so in der richtung habe ich
mir das vorgestellt.
Müssen wir mal gucken,
wie das funktioniert. Also was ich auf jeden Fall
nicht benutzen werde,
ist, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das hier sieht,
ja, den hier, ihr
Synology-Klon, den sie da
entwickelt haben.
Hast du sonst auch alles in 10 GB
ausgebaut?
Da siehst du es.
Alle Kisten laufen natürlich nicht mit 10 GB,
weil Raspberry Pis zum Beispiel kein 10 GB können.
Aber von meinem Desktop
zum NAS
komme ich mit 10 GB.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Ich habe gesehen, meine Netzwerkkarte ist bei mir im Chat
Guck mal hier
Fast
Fast die Netzwerkkarte im Chat
Das ist keine Kupfer-Netzwerkkarte
Das ist mit
SFP Plus Stecker.
Ich hab da so einen
5 Meter
Direct Attach
SFP Plus Kabel, was im Serverraum
an den Switch geht.
Wie durch so einen Kabelkanal da hinter.
Wie länger darf das auch nicht sein?
Müsstest du den SATA Controller...
Ich will den SATA Controller gar nicht.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht.
Nee, wahrscheinlich will ich den SATA Controller nicht durchreichen.
Ich will wahrscheinlich schon ZFS auf dem Host machen.
Weil ich will ja dann auch Proxmox Backups zum Beispiel machen.
Und da braucht man ja Zugriff auf die Discs.
Weiß ich noch nicht. Mal gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeuten soll.
Ach so, Single Mode oder Multi Mode meinst du?
Das ist kein Glasfaserkabel.
Das ist so ein Direct-Attached-Kupferkabel.
Wie viel Scheiße bei Windows mittlerweile läuft, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Echter Witz.
Wolle, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Wo ist eigentlich der Michael?
50 Billiarden.
Der ist doch auch sonntags morgens immer gerne am Start.
Naja, gut.
Ich meine, ich kann nicht erwarten, dass
ich einfach drei Wochen nicht streame und dann
alle wieder am Start sind.
So.
Also, wir haben alles geupdatet. Wunderbar.
Ist das...
Das ist...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das klingt nach Michael Jackson, oder?
Nur in Nintendo-Music-Style.
ÖTF?
Der war da, als ich aufgegangen bin.
Aha.
Was ich jetzt schon öfters hatte,
hier im Explorer.
Ich vermeide ja so viel...
Read me.
Very important.
Comfy UI.
Was war Comfy UI nochmal?
Was war das?
Das war Image Generation.
Okay. Very important. Read.
Very important.
Okay.
Was ich jetzt schon öfters hatte ist,
dass dieses Fenster hier oben
einfach aufgeblieben ist, obwohl ich rumgeklickt
habe.
Das war hier runter
geklappt und ging dann einfach nicht mehr zu.
Das Einzige, was du machen konntest, ist einmal vor und zurück
zu gehen, dann ist es zugegangen. Also das ist so
Buggy-Shit mittlerweile.
Ich bin eh der Meinung,
Windows XP SP3.
Ich hab nicht dran gedacht, dass
es SP3 gibt. Ich hab mal geschrieben SP2.
Windows XP SP3, Leute.
Beste, konsistenteste
Windows gewesen. Nicht, dass man
das heute noch verwenden könnte, aber
von der
Gesamtheit her war das das letzte
Windows aus einem Guss.
Ja, das sind so
Dinger, wo ich mir halt echt vorstelle,
die generieren das mittlerweile intern auch mit AI.
Ja, Windows 11 geht mir auch immer
auf der Arbeit offensack. Aber keine
chance wir müssen wir noch 11 verwenden damit die 100 milliarden security tools im hintergrund laufen
können das erste mal als ich mein notebook aufgeklappt habe als ich dort angefangen habe
auf der arbeit da war also da ist ausgeschaltet gewesen dass das hier so in der taskleiste quasi
hier stopp ist sondern die task diese diese treiber konnte exzellenz und die treiber ist
extended wie bis hier vorne das war alles voll mit icons auf meinem notebook alles von da läuft
sonst was im hintergrund alle auf meinem arbeits notebook glücklicherweise brauche ich meinen
windows notebook nur login auf meine linux kiste um glück sonst würde ich durchdrehen
Du musst noch auf Windows 2000, arbeitest du auf einem Geldautomat oder so?
Also ich habe jetzt schon öfters die Ehre gehabt, in Zoom-Meetings eingeladen worden zu sein.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ist mir Teams deutlich lieber.
Zu den restlichen Funktionen von Zoom kann ich nichts sagen,
weil ich das ja nicht als Daily-Kommunikationsplattform benutze.
Aber rein die Meetings-Geschichten, ganz ehrlich, da gefällt mir Teams besser.
Zoom ist super Painschampig gewesen bei mir.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, ziemlich normal.
Angeblich hat die Bahn nicht letztens sogar noch einen Entwickler für DOS-Systeme gesucht.
Da war doch irgendwie was. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Bahn sucht DOS-Entwickler.
Hier.
Windows 3.11 und DOS.
Alter, diese Webseite.
deutsche bahn sucht administrator für windows 3 11 und ms dos
da läuft viel da läuft viel auf alt auf altem kram
Windows 3.11, muss man immerhin sagen, war immerhin noch so eine konsistente Geschichte.
Das sah alles nach Windows 3.11 aus.
Nicht wie unter Windows 11, wo 20, 30 Jahre Windows-Geschichte gestückelt sind.
Übrigens Chat, wo wir gerade mal wieder dabei sind.
Hier.
Settings.
Wo? Hier.
Guck mal.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, Chat.
Wie?
Wie gucke ich mir hier überhaupt meine IP-Adresse an?
Ethernet 2 not connected.
Okay.
Und wo sehe ich jetzt meine...
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wo, wo, bitteschön,
ist hier meine Netzwerkkarte?
Wo ist meine Netzwerkkarte?
Mit der ich gerade verbunden bin.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht,
was Microsoft mit diesen Settings macht.
Ich will mir einfach meine IP angucken
und welche Netzwerkkarte ich verwende.
Ja, guck mal,
ist es connected? Ich gehe hier hin und
es ist nicht connected.
Das ist so hängen geblieben
Also im Prinzip
Bleibt dir doch gar nichts
Was unter Advanced ist das?
Wirklich?
Okay, gucken wir mal
Ne
Ah, ah
Hier
Alter
Wo ist meine IP?
Ja
Da ist es.
Alter, ist das beknackt.
Alter, ist das bescheuert, man.
Ich mein,
Windows oder Microsoft,
wie wäre es mal,
die aktive Verbindung hier anzuzeigen?
Das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Früher bist du hier hingegangen.
Das konnte man ja früher noch mit einem
Klick aufmachen. Und dann hat es
bis hier drauf gegangen und hat alles gesehen. So, gut.
Okay, bist du nicht? Hier steht auch nicht die IP, aber
hier steht die IP.
Keine Ahnung, was mit dem los ist.
Richtig lost,
Alter.
Ah, das habe ich mir hier gebuckmarkt.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Die Treiber-Version und irgendwelche komischen Dinge
als die IP-Adresse, ja.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Das interessiert den normalen User auch extrem.
Und mich würde wirklich nicht wundern, wenn Microsoft den Kram vibe-coded mittlerweile.
Der Chef von Microsoft hat doch letztens auch in so einer Rundmail an seine Mitarbeiter gesagt,
wer keinen Bock auf AI-Kram hat oder nicht AI-first machen will oder was auch immer, der soll besser abhauen.
Toll, ne? Genauso wirkt ja der Kram von Microsoft auch.
Es gab doch hier dieses...
Es gab doch mal so ein lustiges Video.
Auf YouTube, ehrlich gesagt.
Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen.
Microsoft AI...
...Compilation.
Irgendwie sowas.
Da gab es...
Das finde ich nicht mehr.
Da gab es ein Video, da wurde zusammengeschnitten,
wie oft Microsoft AI gesagt hat.
Und das ist irgendwie ein 11-Minuten-Video,
wo eigentlich nichts anderes vorkommt als AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Das finde ich nicht mehr.
Mario, danke schön für den Sub.
51 Monate.
Excellent.
Hi IQ.
Tja, bei mir nicht. Fragt man sich, was Microsoft da wieder gebaut hat.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub trendet.
GitHub.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Was trendet denn hier?
This week.
AI.
Hä?
Ja, natürlich.
Was sonst?
AI.
Was ist das?
Videos mit React?
But why?
aha okay
ei ei ei ei ei wobei da steht weib das heißt nicht automatisch aber claude hat hat gebildet
es ist war es ist nicht er ist es weib coded rechtlich ist vor every vibe okay das ist doch
kram
etwa fein sich sehr viel 50 direkt ist ein test test 2 ja das habe ich auch
Das brauchen wir nicht.
AI.
Geil.
Im Prinzip, bis auf eine Sache, alles AI.
Sag mal.
Waren die Trends schon immer so kurz?
Warnt Stadttrack normalerweise mehr drin?
Als
8 Stück?
Da waren doch immer mehr.
Ist das irgendwie kaputt?
Okay, jetzt hängt GitHub komplett.
Hä? Warum sind das nur noch so wenige?
Es waren doch immer mehr.
Von dem Nvidia-Typ, der sagt AI.
AI.
Ja.
So ein ähnliches habe ich auch von Microsoft.
Ich muss mal überlegen, das geht eine Minute 42 und dass es ja immer aus Sätzen rausgeht, da ging es wirklich nur wieder um AI.
Okay, anscheinend gibt es es nicht mehr.
Vielleicht, wenn man die Language auf Go stellt.
Mal gucken, was dann passiert.
Ach, dann ist es wieder mehr.
Hä?
Und wenn man es jetzt wieder auf Annie zurückstellt?
Was ist das schon wieder für komisches Zeug?
Übrigens, GitHub gibt es ja in der Form nicht mehr.
Die wurden jetzt quasi bei Microsoft komplett einsortiert, habe ich in den letzten News gelesen.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Downloader?
Was ist das hier?
Weiß man nicht.
Ah, guck mal, da gibt es sogar was auf Englisch.
REST-Downloader.
Ai Xiang...
Resource-Downloader.
Was ist denn das? Ist das ein China-YouTube oder...
Was?
Äh.
Hä?
Was ist das?
Ich hab legit kein blassen Schimmer, was ich hier am sehen bin.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
cloud native manager okay was soll man sich darunter vorstellen cloud native manager alles klar
ist cloud native computing foundation projekt ja schön
selbst service engineering plattform
Kubernetes Infrastructure.
Aha.
Okay. Whatever.
Go to RTC.
Das habe ich auch eine Weile verwendet.
Meine Webcams
zu streamen.
Beziehungsweise mal ausprobiert.
Aber ich benutze nach wie vor mein eigen gebasteltes Zeug.
Oh Lama. Okay wenigstens mal AI-Kram.
Den ich kenne.
Den ich auch benutze.
Für lokale Models.
Ich bin jetzt hier von
lm studio eigentlich weg ich benutze jetzt nur noch olama und laden wir die models dann über
hoging face mcp server für github aber nicht genug stellt das ist recht recht bekannt das
Projekt so im
kubaniertes Umfeld. Netzwerk-Kram.
AI.
Ein weiterer Terminal-Based-Editor.
Da haben wir ja noch nicht genug.
Temporal Service. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was
das sein soll. Service.
I.O.
Was?
Okay, ich habe den ersten Satz gelesen und keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Temporal ist eine durable execution platform,
die Entwickler ermöglicht, skalierbare Applikationen zu bauen,
ohne die Produktivität oder die Verleihbarkeit zu zerstören.
Hä?
Was?
Kann mir das einer mal irgendwie übersetzen, was das eigentlich sein soll?
Alter, das ist so eine Workflow-Engine.
Irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Agentic Coding.
AI, AI, AI.
Naja, gut.
Hier noch AI.
Ich hab's
auch nicht richtig zuordnen können.
Was die da eigentlich
mit meinen...
So richtig verstanden hab ich's immer noch nicht.
Das ist oftmals
was, was ich bei eigentlich ganz
coolen Projekten sehe.
Die haben dann zwar eine...
Glücklicherweise haben die mittlerweile schon oftmals Readme's
mit Screenshots, weil ich find Readme's ohne Screenshots
immer ziemlich nicht so werbe wirksam aber die müssen einfach mal den ersten
zwei sätzen am besten im ersten satz musst du verstehen was das eigentlich ist
also nicht jemand der sich voll schon damit auskennt für den ist die mit mir
nicht zumindest nicht der erste satz von jemand der keine ahnung hat was das
produkt ist oder was das projekt ist muss der erste satz muss gleich so dass
du verstehst okay was ist das eigentlich
Warum habe ich hier eigentlich den Switch offen?
Was eigentlich ein ziemlich nicer Switch ist, ne?
Achtmal, 2,5 Gig.
Zweimal 10 Gig.
USB für irgendwelche Images oder so.
Für PXE-Boot.
Leute, das machen wir übrigens demnächst im Stream.
pxe boot zu ipx e2 wollte ich schon lange mal bauen zu installer image zu debian cloud image
so irgendwie so also was ich vorhabe ist und ich muss das anders sagen ihr kennt das doch
wer beispielsweise wer beispielsweise mal hätte noch verwendet ein gutes beispiel ja da klickt
man ja sich relativ einfach mit server zusammen da sagst du hier ich will was hast du hier ich
will ein jahr mit ihrer server dinge leider gibt es mein lieblings aber nicht mehr mein
Lieblingsserver war der mit drei Cores, aber den gibt's nicht mehr.
Und dann sagst du, hier will die Kiste haben,
ähm, in Nürnberg
und dann klick, klick, klick,
äh, diese SSH-Key, klick, klick
und gut ist. So.
Und dann startet das Ding und ein paar Sekunden später
hast du eine Cloud-Kiste mit frischem Debian.
So.
Ich hätte gerne
sowas ähnliches
für mich lokal im Netzwerk.
Für VMs,
für irgendwelche Mini-PCs,
für was auch immer. Sondern was ich mir überlegt habe,
was man hier eigentlich machen könnte, ist,
man könnte sich einen PXE-Server installieren.
Der PXE-Server, also das müssen wir dann bauen,
der PXE-Server macht nichts anderes wie,
der macht zwei Sachen, der macht zwei Sachen.
So.
Also der PXE-Server liefert letztendlich IPXE aus.
IPXE ist ein moderneres PXE,
also PXE ist Netzwerkboot im Endeffekt.
Du kannst über das Netzwerk,
du kannst, nee, nee, nee, nicht VM-Champ,
ich will das über PXE machen,
dann geht das nämlich überall.
Theoretisch sowas wie ein Ventoy-Server
Nee, nee, nee
Bei Ventoy würdest du ja verschiedene ISOs
Booten, das will ich nicht
Ich will eigentlich nur ein Debian-Cloud-Image installieren können
Zumindest über PXE
PXE guckt nach
Also, die PXE-Kiste
Guckt nach, ist das was mit
BIOS-Boot oder ist das was mit UEFI-Boot
Und liefert dann jeweils ein passendes
IPXE-Image
IPXE ist ein bisschen moderner, geht über HTTP
Und lädt einfach deutlich schneller als
TFTP-Shit
Deswegen der erste Step muss sein, zu schauen, was wird gebootet, ein passendes über PXE, ein passendes IPXE-Image auszuliefern.
So, dann will ich mir ein minimales Linux bauen, was von irgendeinem RAM-Disk läuft, was von IPXE gestartet wird.
Auf diesem Linux kann ich dann sowas wie beispielsweise, keine Ahnung, setup.sh, das muss natürlich da alles reingebacken werden,
starten
und
dann, was ist Boot C? Boot C
kenne ich nicht.
Mal kurz gucken.
Gleich.
So, und da kann ich dann
sagen hier Install.sh
oder irgendwie sowas.
Dann bekomme ich eine Auswahl, willst du Debian Stable, Testing oder Unstable haben?
Und dann fragt er mich, auf welche Festplatte.
Und dann wird einfach das aktuelle Debian Cloud Image auf die Festplatte DDed gebootet.
Und dann über Cloud Init konfiguriert.
Cloud Init muss ich da auch noch irgendwie reinbacken.
Das ist dann fast wie ein bisschen
Wie man das bei irgendwelchen Cloud-Anbietern macht
Nur lokal
Also mal gucken wie das funzt
Schauen wir mal
Was ist GitHub Boot C
Boot and upgrade
Via Container
Was
Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das was ist, um
VMs mit
einem Debian zu installieren.
Ansonsten verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, was es ist.
Okay, ich checke es nicht genau, was es ist.
Aber wir bauen das selbst.
Oh, was ist bei N8N?
Ganz ehrlich, PXE, ich habe letztens schon ein bisschen damit rumgespielt, ist pain in the ass, Alter.
Außerdem ist PXE super
So
Schwarze Magie
Bin mal gespannt
Schicke Oberfläche
Ich brauch keine Oberfläche
Das Ding bootet über PXE
Ich bekomme über PXE
Vielleicht noch eine Auswahl
Auswahlmenü lokal booten netboot xyz booten oder mein installer ram image booten
Und dann starte das installen wir mal gucken ich habe noch keine ahnung wie man vielleicht vielleicht also chat wenn es mir heute ganz gut geht
Läuft wirklich michael jackson oder
Michael Jackson im Nintendo Musik Style
The fuck?
KQ
Ja das ist nicht Toss in der Variante
wir können eine andere playlist aber die haben jetzt schon ein paar mal durch
was jetzt zu
So, dann, da wollte ich übrigens gar nicht draufklicken.
Zum Glück hat er auch nicht geklickt.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
99 pro 1 Terabyte.
Wie ist dann die Preisentwicklung?
Ha, von 100 auf 170, Alter.
Ja.
Von 1, Alter, ist das teuer geworden.
Fuck. Guckt mal.
Von 79.
Von 79 Euro.
Auf 166.
Das ist mehr als das Doppelte.
Und die 2 Terabyte Variante.
Ja, ähnlich.
ähnlich es gab hier mal ein angebot für 97 euro für eine 2 terabyte ssd mittlerweile alter
mit 240 euro okay gehen wir mal realistischer aus so hier soja ok vielleicht nicht diese super
billigen dinger geben wir mal irgendwie von hier so ein bisschen was realistisch 140 ja von 140
auf 240. Ist halt auch schon krass.
Selbst als
die Dinger halbwegs neu waren. Moment mal.
Max, Max. Ja gut, als die neu waren,
als die neu waren, waren die noch
teurer. Okay.
Hier irgendwo habe ich meinen Rechner
gekauft. Das heißt,
ich habe damals sogar noch mehr bezahlt als heute.
Wir haben neulich drei Server gekauft und jetzt ist der RAM in den Servern mehr wert, als die Server gekostet haben.
Tja.
Was kostet... Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich habe hier noch 32 GB DDR5.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal.
Ähm...
War ab und zu keine Ahnung.
32 GB DDR5 SO-DIM.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Geschwindigkeit hat.
Boah!
Das könnten die tatsächlich sein, die ich habe.
Die sehen ähnlich aus
Zu meinen RAM-Riegeln
Ordentlich
Gut, gut, dass ich die noch hab
UVP 400 Euro
Jaja, Amazon
Jaja, jaja
Krasser Scheiß, wie teuer das ist mittlerweile
heftig
beibringt nicht, wenn man da guckt
nehmen wir mal einfach hier
okay, das ist der RGB-Stelz
boah, der war schon immer teuer
boah, alter
guck mal die Rampfreise an
hier
Mitte letzten Jahres 109, 109 Euro.
Und jetzt 480.
Was ist mit euch los?
Ich glaube, neuen PC bauen ist gerade eine schlechte Idee.
Wie sieht es eigentlich bei Apple aus?
Also Apple Geräte sind, also das ist so ein bisschen Hörensagen, ich habe mir selbst keinen gekauft, aber Apple Geräte müssen wohl, wenn man lokale AI Models laufen lassen möchte, bisschen größere lokale AI Models, müssen Mac Minis wohl der Preis-Leistungsschitt schlechthin sein.
weil Mac Minis haben ja auch diese
Unified Memory Geschichte
und für
AI Anwendungen selbst müssen Mac Minis
richtig gut sein
was kosten, gucken wir mal kurz
was kosten aktuell
was kosten aktuell so ein Mac Mini
da gucken wir bei
Apple Direkte
M4 Max ist
Mac Studio, die Dinger sind doch brutal teuer, oder?
Wie viel kostet denn ein
M4 Max?
Das ist doch übelst teuer
Studio
Naja
Das geht eigentlich
Das geht eigentlich klar. Wobei ab, ab, ab, das ist ja Apple ab.
Die Apple Webseite fuckt schon ein bisschen ab, oder? Dass man nicht einfach runterscrollen kann.
Alter Apple, ich will doch einfach nur gucken was drin ist, man.
Und wie viel RAM hat der?
Kaufen.
Wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, als ob.
Äh, warum sieht die Seite so kacke aus?
Legt er mal im Darkreader.
Nehmen wir mal den da.
Wählen.
Wählen?
Belassen wir das mal?
Alter, Ram lassen, die sich aber echt gut bezahlen.
ram lassen die sich ja wirklich gut bezahlen da kannst du nichts sagen
naja man kann übrigens gar nicht mehr kaufen oder die gibt es gar nicht mehr
es gibt es gibt nur 32 gig die anderen kamen gar nicht mal anklicken
Andere CPU? Achso, muss ich das da wählen?
Ah, okay.
So, aber ganz im Ernst,
wenn man wirklich lokale Models
laufen lassen will,
dann ist das...
Also wenn man da...
Vielleicht für privat nicht, ja?
Aber wenn du jetzt beispielsweise eine Firma hast und hast irgendein digitales Dokumentenmanagement-System, wo du AI deine Dokumente indexieren lassen willst, was durchaus sinnvoll ist, dann ist sowas halt wirklich nice.
dann ist das preislich auch wirklich okay guck mal mal wenn wir mal hier gpt
ist das gpt oss ist wie groß hier 65 das kann man richtig gut auf so eine apple kiste laufen lassen
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
eine auswahl was da gut ist dafür so ein dokumentenmanagement system das jetzt
beispielsweise das programmieren gedacht ganz gut sondern sagt man jetzt hier wo
ist der knopf views des model pros quantität dass da das kann man auch gut
auf eine apple kiste laufen lassen hier dann 28 gig
in einem 4.7 gm 4.7 flash ist gut dafür ja und man muss das model pros
quantität quantität ist so eine art komprimierung bei lms oder bei models
ja guck mal das kannst du richtig gut auch so eine apple kiste laufen lassen
So, jetzt konfigurieren wir mal ein Mac.
Gute Idee.
Jetzt konfigurieren wir mal ein Mac Mini.
Mac Mini.
Die Dinger sind auch ziemlich stromsparend, habe ich gehört.
Was braucht denn so ein Mac Mini?
Beispielsweise Idle Power Consumption.
20, das ist in Ordnung.
Wenn man so einen Anwendungsfall für sowas hat.
Ist das vollkommen okay?
Ach ne, hier 3 bis 7 Watt.
Das ist super.
Das Ding eidelt ja auch nicht
Jetzt haben wir mal einen nicht unerheblichen Teil
Ey, das ist eigentlich richtig geil, Leute
Das ist eigentlich richtig geil
Jetzt bin ich
Jetzt bin ich am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht so ein Ding
Für lokale AI-Models kaufen soll
Hat wieder
Haben sie mich wieder abgesellt
Ja gut, ne, da müsste ich erstmal was anderes kaufen
Chat, ich darf mir sowas nicht angucken, Alter
Beepo, burn money.
Burn money, Leute.
Aber richtig.
Wartet mal kurz.
Irgendwie.
Funzt das nicht so ganz, das Overlay.
Das ist kaputt.
Achso, weil es ein WebM-Image ist.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Gibt es das auch als GIF?
Ah, das gibt es auch als GIF.
Sekunde, Sekunde, ich muss mir das mal speichern
Ich will das hier
In meinem
Jetzt haben wir es
Für den Preis kannst du auch viele Api-Tokens kaufen
Ja, das stimmt
Aber ich will meine lokalen Dokumente, Rechnungen und Briefe und sowas nicht an die AI in die Cloud schicken.
Hm.
Ja, okay, also.
Mac Mini für KI. Zeig mal hier.
Kaufen.
Was haben wir hier?
10 Core?
10 Gig gemeinsame Arbeit, Speicher, SSD.
Wir nehmen einfach mal die kleinsten und konfigurieren.
Das ist alles immer.
Da kann man auch bestimmt auch...
Das ist SSD.
Ja.
Naja gut, ganz ehrlich.
Kann man...
Chat, Chat.
Kann man bei den Mac Minis die SSD selber tauschen?
Dass Apple das nicht will, ist mir klar.
Die ist drauf gelötet oder so wahrscheinlich.
Nein, ja, nein.
Nein, aber über Thunderbolt.
Ach, eine weitere SSD über Thunderbolt.
Ab M4, ja, geht.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Okay, YouTube.
Mac Mini M4 Change SSD.
How to upgrade Mac Mini SSD and save hundreds.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Äh.
Was ist das?
Kein Sound.
Wir brauchen da keinen Sound für.
Wir gucken uns das an.
Ach ja, der hat da ein Video.
Das hier meinst du?
Okay, das gucken wir uns an.
Das interessiert mich in der Tat.
Aber vorher...
Vorher...
Ähm...
Vorher klicke ich mir das mal zusammen.
Okay, sagen wir mal 512 GB.
Ja, kostet ein bisschen mehr.
In Ordnung.
Die absellen mir das ja schön wieder.
So, wählen.
32 Gig gemeinsamer Arbeitsspeicher.
Äh, Chat, Chat.
Das bringt mir gar nichts.
Nicht so wirklich.
Ich hab ne...
Ich hab ne 4090, GTX 4090 mit 24 Gig RAM.
Es gibt jetzt nicht so viele Models, die mich mehr interessieren, die ich da drauf laufen lassen könnte.
Ja gut, aber, aber, ja ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
der vorteil ist der vorteil ist dass das ding fast nichts zieht und sonst für die für die 40
90 müsste ja mein rechner an sein auf der anderen seite für 1450 euro kann ich mein
rechner ganz schön lange an lassen gibt es gibt es das hier auch noch mit mehr
speicher als 32 gb ist ein bisschen wenig oder kommt da noch der grafik
speicher dabei wie ist das ist das 32 gb das sind 32 gb insgesamt
Klick auf das vierte Modell in der Liste.
Äh, Moment.
Mini.
Das vierte Modell in der Liste.
Aber Moment, hier kaufen.
Es gibt kein viertes Modell.
Es gibt nur das.
Da unten!
da unten vor jetzt wird es aber schon eine ganze ecke teurer
m
moment dafür hätten wir noch fast studio bekommen
Moment.
Ne, ne, ne, Moment.
Das Studio hat 4000 noch was bekommen.
Kann man hier wählen?
Apple Upsell
baitet immer gut, ja.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Es ist doch ein Unterschied.
Okay.
Also hier, 64 Gig.
Boah, das ist aber schon
ein stattlicher, stattlicher Preis.
Ja, 4.174 Euro.
Also das werde ich mir nicht für lokale Models gönnen, Leute.
Das ist es mir nicht wert.
Muss die 64er miteinander vergleichen.
Ja, guck mal.
Trotzdem ordentlicher Unterschied.
16-Core, 40-Core-GPU.
20-Core-GPU.
Okay.
Naja.
Das ist ganz ehrlich.
Das ist mir dann doch nicht wert.
Dann mache ich lieber meinen Rechner an, wenn ich irgendwelche Dokumente mal indexieren will.
Jetzt mal was anderes.
Wir haben doch hier GLM 4.7 gerade.
Wir müssen mal was ausprobieren.
Wir müssen gerade mal was ausprobieren.
Gucke mal hier.
Das passt doch gut rein.
GLM 4.7.
Sekunde.
Wartet mal.
LM Studio.
Wir probieren das mal kurz aus.
Wir probieren das mal kurz.
Ich lass den mal in den Text zusammenfassen, okay?
Ähm.
Ja, ja.
Okay, wir updaten LM Studio mal.
Schadet sicherlich nix.
Ist das jetzt, hat das jetzt relaunched?
Es hängt.
Okay.
Ah.
Äh.
Hat sich Ella im Studio gerade selbst zerstört?
Kann das sein?
Oh, jetzt, jetzt.
Okay, es war noch mitten im Installieren.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Es war noch mitten im Installieren.
so glm 4.7 flash hol gpu laut passe possible ok ok
Okay, Stellenanzeige
Java Wizard
Hatten wir doch mal irgendwas
Gibt's nicht, okay
Weiter Bahn, okay, eine Bahnstellenanzeige
DevOps, gucken wir mal
Jobs für IT-Professionals
Finde jetzt einen passenden
Ja, Hessen natürlich
Frankfurt
Wähle deine Stelle aus
Okay, was haben wir hier
Java Backend Entwickler, DB Navigator und Bahn
Exakt
Jetzt bewerben
Also
Das Model hat nicht so einfach Zugriff aufs Internet
Deswegen muss ich das reinkopipasten
Okay
Aber das lädt immer noch runter
Na gut, das dauert jetzt kurz
So, wir vergleichen das jetzt mal
Mit Chat-GPT
Ja
Fasse mir diese
Stellen
Stellenanzeige
In 5 Sätzen
Zusammen
Fasse mir
Die wichtigsten Punkte
Dieser Stellenanzeige
In 5 Sätzen zusammen
dann können wir google noch fragen
und dann machen wir den direkten vergleich wir fragen
was
heute morgen ging ging ging das doch noch
ist es klm 4.7 nicht mehr free bei opencode
jetzt kohle ein stück für den sub ok keine ahnung also ich hab's euch heute
morgen gezeigt und morgen war das noch
Morgen war das noch free.
Ja, geil.
Grip.
Okay, so.
Das sind fünf Sätze.
Das sind aber ganz schön lange Sätze.
Okay, machen wir es in fünf kurzen Sätzen zusammen.
Stichpunkte. Gute Idee, Chat.
Ja, so ist das gut. So ist das gut.
Fasse mir die wichtigsten Punkte
in
Stichpunkten
zusammen.
Okay.
Das ist die ganze Stellenanzeige einfach nochmal.
Was sind die wichtigsten Punkte in kurzen, ok in kurzen Stichpunkten?
Fassen wir die wichtigsten Punkte kurz, kurz
Kurz in Stichpunkten zusammen
Naja, naja
in wenigen stichpunkten zusammen okay engineering live so kurz und knapp wichtigste punkte position
ja aber das geht das ist nicht schlecht das ist nicht schlecht okay da geht es ja überhaupt nicht
darum ok google checks google checkt überhaupt nicht schreibt auf englisch obwohl sie deutsche
stellen anzeige ist die frage in deutsch gestellt alles klar das ist schon doof
dass sie irgendwie er kam nicht mal kostenloses sagt
Pech.
Also, Downloaden, gleich ist fertig runtergeladen.
Dann probieren wir jetzt mal das im Vergleich aus mit GLM 4.7 Flash, wenn es auf meiner
GPU läuft
Was meint ihr wie schnell so was auf dem nass laufen würde mit fünf kernen
bestimmt super langsam so ein token pro sekunde oder so weil es hat keine gpu hat aber genug ram
zwei bis vier tokens es wäre nicht schlimm ganz ehrlich für für dokumente
in der indexieren oder zusammenfassen per ai so dass man sie danach ordentlich
durchsuchen kann ist es egal ob das eine viertelstunde dauert pro dokument weil
es wird eingescannt und abgelegt
als müssen wir doch hier irgendwie einstellen gpu auf laut alles auf 100 prozent
weil ich bin gerade überlegen ob ich mir nicht wenn ich mir das neue last kaufe
ab paperless draufhauen soll mit indexierung für meine dokumente da ist dann auch so fragen
kann sie ja hier waren war die letzte rechnung an den und den und was hat es gekostet und sowas
wobei ich das halt auch das indexieren das kann ich halt auch machen lassen mit
der gpu vom rechner das geht halt auch
ok
klirren messages okay das jetzt wollen wir mal was du mir die wichtigste die wichtigste
punkt kurz in wenigen stichpunkten zusammen und es ist es ist es riesen
ist riesen
hier sind die wichtigsten punkte der stellanzeige kurz zusammengefasst
position java bergen entwickler in der aufgabe weiter wegen der apps code
reviews ist die agile teamarbeit scrum kann bahn optimierung das ist gar nicht
so schlecht oder benefits 16 freifahrten pro jahr ach okay mehr netz muss da ich
alles frei sein wenn du bei der bahn arbeitest weil du musst ja immer noch
mit dem scheiß auseinandersetzen und dann auch noch im shop und profil
erfahrungen microservice test ganz ehrlich ich finde diese zusammenfassung
gar nicht so gar nicht so übel
Das ist gar nicht so übel.
Falls sie richtig ist.
Ja, das weiß man immer nicht so genau.
Drei.
16 Freifahrt, na immerhin.
Kann?
Kann GLM 4.7
7 auch texterkennung beispiel rechnung pdf muster rechnung klein oder perfekt exzellent ihr car
stellst und bei texterkennung kann dann kann dann durchaus paperless für mich
auch mal desktop moment zag upload upload file desktop echt ein kleiner
unternehmer was ist der betrag in der rechnung
ok mama
kunst kunst es ist kein ocr es ist eine pdf also muss ein pdf scannen wir können mal wir
können mal gucken wir können mal gucken wenn das ein bild ist ja okay wenn das ein wenn das
ein bild ist wo habe ich denn jetzt hier rechnung nach oben rechnung machen ein bild davon
Paint, was sonst?
Bam, Rechnung.
Haben wir hier, zack.
Save.
Desktop.
Rechnung.
Okay.
Chat.
Neuer Chat.
Upload.
Ich kann mal Chico hochladen und fragen, was da drauf ist.
Oh.
Model does not support
Image-Input.
Okay.
Da musst du dich einloggen,
wenn du das benutzen willst.
Was ist ein gutes OCR?
Gibt es hier irgendwie OCR-Models oder so?
Ich habe mich noch nie mit beschäftigt.
Olmo
CR.
Was ist ein gutes OCR-Model?
Keine Ahnung, das probieren wir jetzt nicht aus.
Es ist auch vollkommen egal.
Das lasse ich dann paperless machen.
Das OCR stellt es mit.
Habt ihr das auch manchmal?
Edge will irgendwelche Dinge anpinnen, wenn du es schließt.
So hängen geblieben.
Damit muss ich mich demnächst mal beschäftigen.
Pepper, lass stell's.
Also was ich jetzt gelesen habe ist, dass das Probleme hat, wenn die Qualität halt nicht so gut ist.
und dass da manche Models oder in Kombination damit, dass du deutlich besser den Text rauskriegst.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du die Sachen nicht schön einscannst, sondern einfach nur abfotografierst mit dem Handy.
Da hat Tesseract Probleme und mit AI-Model-Unterstützung ist das wohl deutlich besser.
Ganz ehrlich, ich fotografiere lieber mal schnell in Rechnung mit dem Handy, anstatt die in den Scanner-Einzug zu schieben.
every man cluster
moment
wort ich das video
ja chat ich hab zu viele tabs auf
ok ssd m4 mac mini
das genau
Ich mache Video-Arbeit und die mehzliche 256 GB Storage in der Basis-Modelle ist einfach zu klein für das.
Apple hat endlich ihr Max zu mindestens 16 GB RAM geupgradiert, was großartig ist, aber ihre Basis-Storage ist noch klein.
Ich meine, es gibt jetzt individuelle Spiele, die dein ganzes Disk aufbauen würden, wenn du die Basis-Modelle kaufst.
Und vergesst iCloud. Ein paar moderne Apps auf dem Mac werden auch all deine Storage verdienen.
Und sprichend von Erfahrung mit einem 256 GB MacBook Air, ist es schmerzhaft, externen Disk zu managen, wenn dein interner Drive nur so klein ist.
Also ist Apples Antwort ein Verlustaufgabe. Du kannst bis zu 2 TB Verlust aufbauen, was großartig ist.
Aber was nicht großartig ist, ist das verrückte Preisverlust für diese Verwaltung. Apple sagt, 2 TB kostet 800 $.
Selbst wenn man vielleicht Apple mit den schnellsten, besten NAND Flash Chips auf der Welt nutzt, die sie nicht haben,
Das ist ein 600 Dollar Premium, der Preis eines gesamten extra Mac Mini über einen standard 2TB M.2 NVMe Drive.
Das ist einfach verrückt. Aber ich bin ein Idiot. Ich habe den Apple-Tax bezahlt. Ich habe meine Maschine zu 1TB verbessert,
nur weil ich nicht genug vorgleichbar bin, um den vollen Preis für 2TB zu bezahlen. Aber hätte ich darüber wissen können,
hätte ich zu dem 256GB Basismodell gestanden. Denn das ist ein 2TB-Übergang für den M4 Mac Mini.
komplett intern und kostet 260$. Das ist immer noch mehr als ein normaler 2TB NVMe-Driven,
aber nicht zu viel. Das ist das 2TB SSD-Expansion-Modul für den Mac Mini M4 und kommt aus Expand
Mac Mini, einem Projekt von FIDE Innovations.
Was ist das?
Cancel.
Chat!
Seid ihr schon drin?
Hä? Zeit ist schon drin, ja?
Gut.
Pay with was? Mit was soll ich payen?
Uh.
Auch teurer geworden.
Ist das irgendwie Deutschland?
Okay.
Ja.
Bei AliExpress gibt es auch welche, okay.
Mac Mini M4 SSD Extension.
Was gibt es denn da, wenn man hier...
Ja gut, aber...
Achso, bei Amazon.de, alles klar.
Okay, also bei Amazon kriegt man den Kram auch.
Na gut, gucken wir uns erstmal das Video an.
Das erste Mal, dass ich das möglich fand, war beim Zuschauen dieses Videos von DOSDUDE1.
In dem Video ging er durch den Prozess, die kleinen NAND-Flashchips auf den Apple-Preinstallationen
der Fabrik zu verändern.
Aber hier ist das Problem.
DOSDUDE1 ist ein Künstler.
Er ist wie Picasso beim Säubern.
Und wenn du keine Erfahrung hast, mit modernen Computerchips zu hacken, dann wird so eine
Operation nicht gut enden.
Glücklicherweise, und trotz dessen, was Tim Apple dir sagen wird, sind Macs nicht aus
Magie und Pixie Dust hergestellt.
Sie haben die gleichen Art von Circuit-Boards und Chips wie jeder andere Computer, zumindest
wenn es um Storage geht.
Und das bedeutet, dass es nicht so schwer ist, Apple's proprietäre Storage-Karte-Design
zu überwinden.
Und genau das ist es, was das Expand Mac Mini macht.
Und das Ding ist nicht die einzige Upgrade-Option.
Ich habe auch dieses M4-SSD-Kits für etwas mehr gefunden.
Und es könnten auch andere Optionen sein, wenn du dieses Video siehst.
Aber das Expand Mac Mini Kit war das erste, was ich darüber herausgefunden habe.
Als Fidesz-Founder mich auf e-mailen und fragte, ob er mir einen testen könnte, war ich
all over it. So yes, I didn't pay for this upgrade kit. It was sent to me for review
and I wanna be fully upfront about that. So my goal today is to see if I can upgrade this
thing from my painfully expensive 1TB module to a much cheaper 2. But before I take this
thing under the knife, I wanted to run a few tests for comparison. Using amorphous disk
mark, I got speeds from 2 to 3 GB per second when doing sequential reasoning.
Sieht original aus wie...
Wie heißt das Ding für Windows Crystal Disk Mark, gell?
Nur dass es schwarz-weiß ist und nicht grün.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Wird der neue Drive schneller werden?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich benutze immer Fio unter Linux.
Bevor ihr so etwas ausprobiert, macht sicher, dass ihr eine komplette Backup habt, wie bei Time Machine.
Oder, wenn ihr wie ich seid, macht sicher, dass ihr eure Mac von Anfang an mit eurem Ansible Automation Playbook verbinden könnt.
Das Kit kommt in eine Box mit dem Chip, der durch dieses kleine Fenster zu sehen ist.
Das ist ein schöner kleiner Touch.
Und wie ich schon gesagt habe, macht sicher, dass ihr eine Backup habt, bevor ihr das ausprobiert, weil es sehr zerstörerisch sein könnte.
Wie das hier ausgestaltet wird, sieht es aus, als ob es einen NAND-Flashchip auf beiden Seiten gibt.
Ich glaube, dass jeder ein Terabyte ist und dann der andere Terabyte.
Und der Konnektor ist so ähnlich wie ein M.2-Druck, aber nicht ganz.
Natürlich muss Apple immer ein bisschen proprietär sein.
Ein paar verschiedene Größen hier für das Entstehen des Mac.
Ich werde sie aussetzen, weil ich hier meinen kleinen, vertrauten, präzisen Schuhdruck habe.
Es ist ein bisschen höherer Qualität.
Und ich weiß nicht, was diese für sind.
Das sind Heatpads, oder? Das sind irgendwelche zu Wärmeableitungen so Pads.
But I need to get into the Mac, so I'm gonna flip it over. It says to put the Jimmy into the gap here.
This is the first time I've tried...
Boah, da hätte ich schon wieder Bedenken, dass ich das Ding irgendwie anbreche oder so.
An M4 Mini, that's not too bad I guess. And it's coming up, so that's good.
Weil es Apple ist.
Das kam endlich auf.
Diese Klippen halten sich ziemlich gut an.
Oh Mann.
Okay. Wow.
Das war nicht so lustig.
Aber es ist offen und ich hoffe, dass ich nichts im Inneren brechen konnte.
Und wenn ich den Power-Switch-Button entfernen möchte, kann ich das annehmen.
Aber das ist ziemlich fest da drin. Ich werde es einfach lassen und das ausmachen lassen.
So, lasst uns mal sehen, ob das T5 ist.
Ja.
T5.
So ein Kit habe ich auch, nur dass meins von iFixit ist.
Ich habe auch noch so ein Vera-Set.
Das benutze ich lieber, weil da kann man gleich den Schraubendreher in die Hand nehmen
und muss dann nicht vorne irgendeinen Bit reinfummeln.
Wobei, wie gesagt, für Spezial-Bits brauche ich das Ding hier trotzdem,
weil die Vera-Dinge haben halt nur ganz normale Köpfe, was man da so halt hat.
Einfach nur in klein.
Ja, dieses, das Ding, also qualitativ gefällt mir das echt gut.
Vera Fine Mechanica Set.
Nope.
Wobei, das könnte es sein.
Ich bin gerade nicht sicher.
Aber so, so, so.
Das muss eine neue Version sein.
Bei mir sehen die Griffe ein bisschen anders aus.
Aber die Dinger sind schon nice.
aber es sind halt nur normale Schraubenköpfe hier. Und wenn man jetzt irgendwelche Spezialdinger hat,
dann benutze ich noch so einen iFixit Toolkit. Ja, so ein Ding hier im Endeffekt ist das.
Da hast du auch alle möglichen besonderen Köpfe drin, die es eigentlich hat, dass man nicht
aufmachen kann. Ich hab damit beispielsweise letztens an meinem Kühlschrank einen neuen
griff dran geschraubt der war auch mit so einer ganzen wirren schraube mit so einem
denen da glaube ich
diesen zwei köpfe
so guck mal weiter
das glaube ich nicht bei apple die sind einfach damit beschäftigt zu gucken wie
welcher blöde effekt besser blöd wir haben ganze abteilung die sich wahrscheinlich nur
um blöde effekte kümmern
much much much better guides out there for taking apart the
m4 mac mini so i am not going to show you the whole process on here this is just yeah
apple seriously come on what is it with all
these wears wow that's a it's only been running for a few months and i'm already
So Dinger kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen, so eine Dose ist das.
Man sieht es jetzt hier nicht.
So Druckluftdosen, ich weiß nicht, wie man die genau nennt.
Da eine parat zu haben, ist enorm praktisch für so Elektronikgebastel.
Einfach, dass man mal schnell was auspusten kann.
Letztens hat es wieder mein Nvidia Shield TV ausgepustet.
wo zwei, drei Mal reingepustet gut ist.
Wobei, was auch cool sein muss,
was ich mir auch schon...
Genau, genau.
Das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt,
ob ich mir sowas kaufen soll.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Dinger heißen.
Es gibt so Mini-Kompressor-Dinger irgendwie.
Nee, wie heißen die Dinger denn?
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Föhn.
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Sowas hier in der Richtung gibt es.
Ja, solche Dinge.
Da weiß ich halt nicht, welche was taugen.
Aber das ist wohl auch ganz nice.
Alfred, was hast du für einen?
Was kannst du da empfehlen?
Ich bin froh, dass Apple es so einfach macht.
Oder? Oder?
Impressum.
Was? Wie?
In den USA sind die.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich ganz hart damit gerechnet, dass die irgendwo bei den China-Chinesen sind.
Das werde ich mir später mal angucken, weil vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch so ein Ding.
Ich glaube das ist sehr nice, das kann man gebrauchen.
Zum Auspusten.
Zum Thema Chunker, bestes Subreddit.
Bestes Upgrade für fette Katzen.
Alter, meine Güte, ey.
Die arme Katze.
So, I guess that's why they include
all these different tips,
because you do need three different sized
tips. That's crazy.
Schau mal auf.
Das geht nicht, weil es Apple ist.
Ja, dass man plus 800 Euro SSDs verkaufen kann.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, man kommt ja für Apple-Verhältnisse noch relativ gut da
dran.
Und es ist nicht irgendwie festgeklebt über Heißwachs oder irgendwie festgelötet oder
so.
Also immerhin, ja.
Also das ist für Apple-Verhältnisse noch super easy.
Apple hat mehr Geld als Atome im Universum.
Das heißt, Geld besteht nicht aus Atomen.
Du brauchst keinen kleinen Marker, weil es sehr offensichtlich ist, wo der Stift ist.
Dieser Socket-Design...
Warum? Warum fühlt Apple sich so aus, als ob sie das tun sollten?
Ah, okay.
Und ich glaube, es passt. Ich habe hier das MacBook Air mit Apple's alten proprietarischen Standard für SSDs.
Ich habe es mit einem OWC-Druck verbessert.
Also hier bin ich, wieder verbessert, viele Jahre später.
Okay, I will crank it down a little bit because Apple did at the factory apparently.
I will say that the engineering of these things is wonderful, but it doesn't need to be as
wonderful if you just use standard parts.
When you're doing the fan screws here...
Das stimmt voll, aber es ist Apple.
They do have rubber grommets, so when you're tightening it, I wouldn't tighten it too
much, just snug.
Hopefully at the factory they actually have like a standard for that.
Das ist echt toll. Apple hat das so gezeichnet, dass es komplett schwarz ist,
bis man die Schrauben aufschließt.
Die kleinen Schraubtücher, die Apple macht.
Es ist verrückt, weil sie es nicht wirklich öffnen,
sondern sie machen es sehr schön auf der Innenseite.
Warum macht ihr nicht beide?
Macht es so, dass die Leute diese Sachen öffnen können und sie genießen.
Ich bin froh, dass sie es nicht komplett abkleben.
oder irgendwas anderes.
Und,
Kraimaro, wie lief das so?
Also, ich werde mir, also ich
hab's mir jetzt überlegt, ich werd mir doch kein Mac Mini
kaufen, weil ganz ehrlich, die
Models kann ich auf meiner Grafikkarte
laufen lassen und
Ich, Dokumentenmanagement kann auch einfach hier Dokumente indizieren, wenn ich meinen Rechner an habe.
Max, was für ein Nass hast du für dein nächstes Projekt rausgesucht?
Das hier.
Das werde ich mir wohl bestellen.
Ganz gute CPU, 4 Efficiency Cores, 1 Performance Core, 10 Gig.
3 Einschübe für SSD, für NVMe SSDs.
und auch wenn da nur zwei steht, es sind drei mit einer intern noch und vier Einschübe für 3,5 Zoll Platten oder SATA SSDs.
Let's get these clips back in.
Maybe.
Warum das HDMI Anschlüsse hat?
Weiß ich nicht, muss den Hersteller fragen.
Aber wir meinen immerhin besser als VGA, oder?
im Jahr 2026.
Aber alte KVMs
haben halt oftmals nur VGA.
Also die kleineren NASes von Ukraine, die haben ja ein bisschen wenig CPU-Power für
Container und VMs, aber wenn man da wirklich nur einfach damit nass machen will, dann ist
Vielleicht auch noch ohne Disk-Encryption, dann geht das bestimmt gut.
Äh, jetzt mal eine blöde Frage.
Warum schließt er den Mac an einem anderen Mac an, anstatt einfach Strom dran zu stöpseln?
Hä? Verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Weil die SSD leer ist, ja und?
Kann man da kein USB...
OS neu aufsetzen?
USB-Stick dran und installieren geht bei Apple nicht, oder was?
Nee?
Geht nur mit anderem Mac? Hä?
Ja, aber wenn ich keinen anderen Mac habe?
Was?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Man muss doch von einem USB-Stick oder irgendwas installieren können.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist meine Mac-Installation mal kaputt
und ich muss es neu installieren oder so.
Das muss doch gehen.
Pech, Pech, wenn das alles kaputt ist, Pech.
Moment mal, das glaube ich euch nicht, Chat.
Moment mal.
Wir fragen jetzt Chat-GPT, okay?
Also.
Kann man seinen Mac Mini M4 mit einem USB-Stick neu installieren?
Ja, das geht. Ha, Chat.
Aber vielleicht habt ihr trotzdem recht, weil Chat-GPT erzählt viel Scheiße, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Einen zweiten Mac zum Erstellen des Sticks.
Ja, okay, ich kann aber den Stick doch auch schon auf dem ersten Mac erstellen.
Ja, aber den kann ich doch schon erstellen noch auf dem ersten Mac, solange er noch läuft.
Okay, Apple-Stells, Alter.
Kann man das mit seinem iPhone machen wenigstens?
Das Dumme ist halt auch, wenn es so ein proprietärer Anschlusskram ist, du kannst die SSD, die
du da ausbaust, halt auch nirgendwo anders mehr verwenden.
Ich weiß nicht über dich, aber ich denke, dass der Upgrade ein großartiges Deal ist.
Soll ich mich erinnern? Diese Lösung kostet 500 Dollar über Apple's eigenes Upgrade.
Ist die Stunde oder so Zeit, die es mir dauerte, den Upgrade in DFU zu restaurieren,
um 500 Dollar wert? Du glaubst es.
Das Schrecklichste ist, dass man noch einen anderen Apple Silicon Mac braucht, um diesen Upgrade zu machen.
Und nicht jeder hat das.
Es wäre toll, wenn Apple mit echten M.2-Schlägen anfängt und die ganze DFU-Dance ausdrückt.
Failing that, I'm at least happy third parties can offer these upgrades now.
Because if nothing else, it'll at least give new life to hundreds of thousands of these base model M4 Minis out in the world once they get dumped in a few years.
And if Apple ever decides to try blocking this kind of upgrade, we revolt.
Before I wrap up, the upgrade does have limitations.
First, you have to go through the uncomfortable process of popping the M4's bottom off.
Ja, das stört mich nicht.
Second, this upgrade only works on the base M4, not on the M4 Pro, at least not yet.
Aha!
Aha! Da habe ich schon mal gelitten.
Das ist cool, dass das geht, aber machen werde ich es nicht.
Ich kaufe mir doch kein Mac Mini, ich habe es mir überlegt.
muss es ja nicht übertreiben mit mit dem hier
wieso kein do it yourself nass und das eine schöne box ist schöne kombination ja also
hast du auf dem mac programmiert
Ne.
Das kenne ich schon.
Das ist, das habe ich gerade gesehen.
Das ist mit der, wo einer den Geschmack von Cola nachgebaut hat.
mal gucken was neue updates gibt kann er nicht sein wie was wie was hier los
Okay, was können wir uns noch angucken?
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
jahre ist 22 wir können uns wieder ein fireship video angucken wo es nicht nur um ei geht
das machen wir jetzt
heuer schipp macht wieder 100 sekunden videos hat tatsächlich was gibt's für
welche waren in honda seconds.net in honda okay das kommt jetzt mal
Ich habe lokale Models in Open Code schon ausprobiert, das war ziemlich ernüchternd.
Die hatten auch alle Probleme mit Tool Usage. Es war ziemlicher Mist.
... in Open Source Platform for building high performance software in virtually every domain.
It can tackle web apps, mobile apps, enterprise software...
Na mobile apps mit .NET ist eklig. Mobile apps heißt Maui und Maui sagt...
Das ist aber nicht mehr.
Ja.
Ne, Webapps sind auch nicht okay. Ich mag Playser nicht.
called the Common Language Runtime,
which handles memory management, garbage collection and security,
so you don't have to.
This allows developers to write code in high-level languages
like object-oriented C-Sharp
or its cooler functional brother F-Sharp
or even the mentally ill cousin...
MonkaS! Visual Basic, Alter!
Visual Basic.
No matter which language you choose,
they all get compiled into an intermediate format...
Ist .NET ein modernes Java?
Nee.
Das ist was Alternatives.
Hat aber gewisse Ähnlichkeiten zu Java.
Sowohl vom Aufbau von C-Sharp her, als auch vom Runtime.
Also ist schon recht ähnlich.
Das stimmt wohl. Also das ist für Web-Anwendungs-Backends mein Lieblings-Framework, ASP.NET Core.
Das heißt immer noch übrigens ASP.NET Core, damit man es nicht verwechselt mit ASP.NET.
ASP.NET ist das alte, ASP.NET Core ist das neue.
Das kommt noch aus Zeiten, wo .NET wieder .NET Core hieß, allerdings mittlerweile .NET ja komplett umbenannt wurde,
zurück umbenannt in .NET, was wiederum nicht zu verwechseln ist mit .NET Framework.
.NET Framework 4.8 ist das alte .NET. .NET Core ist das neue und das wurde jetzt mit Version 5 wieder umbenannt in nur .NET.
Alles klar?
Logisch, oder?
mobile apps and pauli für voll tollen wir sind nicht einfach 123 das haben die gemacht dort
net core 1 dort net core 2 dort net core 3 dort net 5 logisch
und es ist ein name of you and you find packt es vor virtually every use case in the new get
package manager on top of that many third party frameworks in bed.net to give developers die
Ja, nur dass .NET 5 nichts mit nicht der Nachfolger von .NET Framework 4.8 ist.
Diese Microsoft ist ganz, ganz weird.
Rider, Beste.
Und jetzt können wir das C-Sharp-File öffnen und ein paar Kode schreiben.
Es ist eine sehr populär, stark genutztes Sprachsprache, das uns exzellente IntelliSense aus dem Boxen gibt.
Heute bauen wir eine App, die nur Horse Fans heißt.
Und leider müssen wir verifizieren, dass der User 18 Jahre alt ist, um mit der letzten draconischen Legislationen von unseren globalistischen Overlords zu verabschieden.
Um das zu erreichen, werden wir den User zuerst in den Console eingeladen, was wir mit der built-in Console-Klasse können.
Tolle App.
Jetzt wirst du mal Bescheid.
Aber gucken wir uns mal lieber an von Fireship, was es im Jahr 2026 so trenden wird.
Lass mich raten. AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
F-Sharp, F-Sharp ist eine funktionale Programmiersprache auf .NET Basis.
Hab ich persönlich noch nie verwendet.
Hab ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
500 Dollar Smartfridge, has a GPU and displays advertisements, your boss is an AI, your girlfriend is a robot and every...
AI can mostly outperform human CEOs or so, das wundert mich nicht.
...startup pitch sounds like Uber but quantum.
Welcome to the future.
It's somehow both over-engineered and still in beta.
But it's time for the annual tradition, where I wake up the vat of precogs in my garage and tell you exactly what's going to happen this year.
Last year I told you AI agents would be the biggest thing in tech.
Hat er nicht Unrecht gehabt?
Ja, ob der Stock-Market crasht,
kommt nicht drauf an, was Trump wieder erzählt.
Wir haben doch schon ein paar C++-Streams gemacht.
Da siehst du schon mal, dass du dich in C drauf freuen kannst,
sich nicht mit diesem ganzen Mist auseinandersetzen zu müssen.
Ja gut, in den USA brauchst du das ja auch.
In den USA musst du ja auch Hunderttausende verdienen,
weil eine Blinddarm-Operation wahrscheinlich schon 10.000 Dollar kostet.
Der Deutschlandrechtswahl-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-Card-
Was? Wie?
Ey, darf ich nicht gucken.
Okay, 40.000 Franken
zu Euro.
Alter, sind WTF
43.000
Euro für eine Blinddarm-Operation.
Was machst du eigentlich
bei der Gelegenheit,
was machst du eigentlich in den USA,
wenn du wirklich irgendwas Ernstes hast
und operiert werden musst
oder dich behandeln lassen musst,
dann kannst du
dich eigentlich gleich erschießen, oder?
Das ist ja teuer.
Alter.
who need to clean up all the garbage code created by these AI tools.
Moment, das gibt es wirklich?
Ich meine, irgendwie logisch, ja?
Irgendwie logisch.
Vibe Code Cleanup Specialist.
Okay, dieses Bild ist AI-generated.
Also das Bild alleine ist schon AI-generated wahrscheinlich.
...managers who need to clean up all the garbage code created by these AI tools.
Aber wo ist AI selbst gehalten?
Jeder weiß, dass wir in einer Bubble mit Wertungen, die keinen Sinn machen.
Aber die Frage ist, sind wir an der Spitze dieser Bubble oder sind wir noch eine Dezember entfernt von der Spitze?
Ich würde sagen, dass wir noch ein paar Jahre haben, um diesen Hype-Zyklus viel zu halten.
Es ist jetzt ziemlich offensichtlich, dass LLMs als Technologie geplatet sind und nicht wirklich intelligent sind.
Als GPT-5 ein paar Monate ago kam, war es ein großes Verlust und wir sehen nicht die exponentiellen Laufs in der Intelligenz,
die ein wirklich intelligenter, selbstentfüllter AI-System sein sollte.
Oh.
predicted a few years ago. But another sign the bubble's not over yet is the fact that most AI
companies are still private. Eventually a time will come when you see a wave of IPOs in the
stock market to hand these bags from VCs over to the public. And when that wave of IPOs arrives,
you'll know the charade is coming to an end. And there's a good chance that wave comes in 2026,
as SpaceX, OpenAI and Anthropic are all looking to go public with some of the biggest IPOs in the
history of the world. But before that happens, one of the biggest drivers to keep the AI hype
going in 2026 will be robots,
humanoid robots. Just a few
weeks ago, 1x started taking orders
for their
Neo-Robot, which can do your
laundry, wash your dishes, and just
be a friendly, helpful slave that will never
rebel. In addition, figure robots
and Tesla Optimus are being pushed
as replacements for manual labor in factories.
As of today, the tech is still
pretty bad and requires a lot of teleoperation,
but companies like Google and
Nvidia are providing the base technology
die einen Founder zu Frankenstein erlaubt.
Also, ihr könnt euch schon mal vorstellen,
wenn es denn dann wirklich mal gescheite Roboter gibt,
ihr könnt euch vorstellen, was das erste Anwendungsgebiet sein wird.
So wie bei vieler neuer Technologie.
Ist eigentlich jetzt schon klar.
... erheben sich einige Klinker und erheben eine Menge Geld.
2026 ist das Jahr, in dem wir endlich diese Dinge aus der Assemblage-Linie sehen.
Aber was, wenn man sich selbst in einen Robot oder Cyborg verändern könnte?
Well, wearable AI-Tech is another big trend to watch for.
We've already had massive flops like the Rabbit and Humane Pin,
but OpenAI is still in collaboration with Johnny Ive
to make some wearable that will actually be good this time, or so they say.
In addition, you've got old companies like Nike
building things like battery-powered shoes
that will finally allow the white man to jump.
And I can't wait for the NBA to approve this
and see dudes dunking from half court.
But until that day comes, I'd rather just get my entertainment
from virtual worlds in my VR headset.
The Apple Vision Pro was supposed to finally make virtual reality mainstream.
Ja, das ist nicht so eingeschlagen, aber das hat man ja schon vermutet am Anfang, dass das jetzt erstmal so ein Start ist, um die Entwickler reinzukriegen für Apple Vision und dann noch ein günstigeres Modell kommt.
But as I correctly predicted, it was a massive flop.
I got a lot of hate from Apple fanboys for making that prediction, but it's not over for the Vision Pro.
There are rumors of a lower cost version in the works that could turn this flop around.
Mittlerweile macht Meta große Investitionen in die Augmentierte Realität, aber...
Was macht eigentlich das Metaverse?
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe da letztens eine Meldung gelesen, dass das ziemlich im Arsch ist.
Der Zuck.
Dass das wohl extremes Paperburn-Money war.
Vielen Dank.
most of the profit. The only company that really screwed things up is Intel, which is both a chip
designer and a fab. And in 2025, it looked like it was on the verge of going out of business,
but luckily, Trump stepped in and had the US government buy a 10% stake in Intel,
thus preventing the free market from working like a free market. And Intel is poised to continue
its turnaround in 2026. It's just too big to fail. But cloud providers like Azure are having a hard
Aha.
Hat die... Jedes Rechenzentrum kriegt dann sein eigenes Atomkraftwerk?
in Solar- oder Windfarmstätten,
die Zukunft vielleicht diese kleinen Reaktoren in jedem Nachbarland haben.
Was könnte da falsch gehen?
Und wir sehen das bereits aus,
mit Zuckerberg, der mit Oklo einen großen Deal mit Oklo erhielt,
einen Reaktor in Ohio zu bauen.
Aber vielleicht wird dieser Trend nie ausgehen,
weil Computer kälter und schneller werden,
wie Billionen von Malen schneller,
die an absolut zero Temperaturen laufen.
Im Jahr 2025 sahen wir einige große Verbesserungen
in der Quantenkompetenz,
vor allem mit Googles Willowchip.
Dann, nur ein paar Monate zuvor,
hat Google seinen Quanten-Echo-Algorithmus eröffnet,
that measures disturbances.
Ja, warum sehen alle diese Ankündigungs-
Präsentationen so gleich aus mittlerweile?
Die Leute haben die gleiche Mimik, die gleichen Gesten,
die Slides sehen ähnlich aus, das sieht alles ähnlich aus.
Just a few months ago, Google announced its Quantum Echoes-Algorithm
that measures disturbances at the subatomic scale.
The first time in history a quantum computer has actually run
Was war das noch für Zeiten, als eine Präsentation bei Microsoft so ausgesehen hat?
Wie geschwitzt, Alter!
Holy cow, I'm going to have to tough it up now.
Here we go.
What's the $64,000 question for the field?
What is the most asked question that I've received this week?
What the hell are we supposed to do about .NET, Steve?
It's a very good question.
And it's got a very, very clear answer.
Developers.
Der Schlüssel für .NET, der Schlüssel für Industrietransformation, der Schlüssel für Erfolg sind
Also ohne Scheiß, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass mir so eine Präsentation mal lieber wäre, ja?
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Kinderspiel.
In der Zukunft wird jedes regierungseingesetzte Smartphone ein Portal für eure Bankkonten,
eure Location, eure sozialen Medienposts, eure Adult Website Besuche und so weiter werden.
Die UK ist stolz darauf, dass digitale ID's kommen, während die Europäische Zentralbank
letztlich erklärte, dass die Eurozone's digitale Euro Pilot in die nächste Phase geht,
mit dem Pilotprogramm, das sobald Mitte 2027 erwartet wird und der vollen Ausgabe einer digitalen Währung im Jahr 2029.
Sie können unsere Leben nehmen und unsere Freiheit, aber sie können nicht unsere JavaScript nehmen.
Auf der Rückseite wird Node.js immer besser und besser und unterstützt jetzt TypeScript-File mit Type-Stripping.
Mittlerweile wird Dino immer besser und hat jetzt seinen eigenen bültigen Modul-Bundler.
Aber alle Kinder dieser Tage sprechen über Bun.js, ein Runtime, das immer schneller wird, aber auch bültigen Unterstützung hat.
Entropic, genau, Entropic war's, ja.
JavaScript.
Javascript.
Ripple ist so ein Krypto-Blockchain-Verein.
Ihr müsst den Sponsor dieses Videos anschauen.
Ich würde es sehr empfehlen, wie AI funktioniert.
Das N8N Video, ich glaube nicht, dass das so spannend ist.
N8N ist nice, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es so nice ist, dass die irgendeine Sicherheitsprobleme wieder haben.
Für die meisten dürfte es wahrscheinlich egal sein bei der lokalen Installation, wo netzwerktechnisch außer ihnen eh schon keiner hinkommt.
Also wenn man das natürlich irgendwie im Internet freigeschaltet hat, was man nicht machen sollte, dann hat man eventuell dicke Probleme.
Ich wundere mich immer, ich lese das total oft auf Reddit oder auch bei Home Assistant im Forum oder so, dass total viele Leute ihren Kram ins Internet freigeben.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, das machen viele, weil sie denken, das könnte mal in Zukunft sinnvoll sein, brauchen es aber gar nicht wirklich.
Also ich kann das an einer Hand abzählen, wie oft ich mir schon von unterwegs gedacht habe, ey, wenn du jetzt dein Home Assistant mal remote auf dem Handy aufmachen könntest.
Also mir fällt jetzt, wie gesagt, mir fällt jetzt gar kein Anwendungszweck dafür ein.
Zur Not geht es auch mit einem VPN, genau.
Ja, wenn man das wirklich will, VPN.
Mir fällt ein Anwendungsgebiet ein, wo das vielleicht ganz sinnvoll ist und zwar ist das Location Tracking.
Wenn man will, dass ein Home Assistant weiß, wo man gerade ist und daraus auch so Dinge berechnen kann wie geschätzte Ankunftszeit oder sowas, dann ist es ganz sinnvoll, wenn beispielsweise die Home Assistant App die Location reporten kann und das kann die nur, wenn sie an den Home Assistant drankommt.
Aber es gibt ja noch zig andere Möglichkeiten, Location Tracking zu machen als so.
Da braucht man eigentlich gar keinen Zugriff.
Ja, oder wenn die Leute Nextcloud ins Internet freigeben.
Das Letzte, was ich ins Internet freigeben würde, ernsthaft, ist Nextcloud.
Und wenn ich überhaupt jemals was ins Internet freigeben würde,
dann würde ich mir überlegen, geht es mit einem VPN?
Wenn es nicht mit einem VPN geht, wie beispielsweise für Location Tracking,
das funktioniert mit dem VPN nicht gescheit, weil das VPN oftmals nicht aufgebaut ist,
wenn neue Updates gepusht werden sollen und sowas.
Dann nur mit einem ordentlichen Reverse-Proxy davor.
Nicht den Service direkt ins Internet.
Mit einer gescheiten Authentifizierung.
Das kann auch meinetwegen Basic-Auth sein, ja.
Aber Hauptsache ein ordentlicher Reverse-Proxy davor,
dass man nicht direkt an den jeweiligen Service drankommt.
NGINX ist durchaus in Ordnung, ja.
Kann man dafür verwenden.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nehmen.
NGX Beste.
Am streamen, ja.
Ich bin öfters mal am streamen.
Wobei öfters...
Die letzten drei Wochen war ich nicht so wirklich...
Wie sieht es eigentlich aus?
Wo war ich gerade davon?
Ne.
Wann habe ich eigentlich das letzte Mal gestreamt?
Mir ging es die letzten drei Wochen nicht so gut.
Ich habe mir gedacht...
Aha.
Passende Werbung am Start.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt selbst ein paar Cents farmen, weil ich mir meine eigene Werbung angucke.
Und eigentlich nur gucken.
Ah, vor 14 Tagen war ich tatsächlich zu Deadzone.
Okay, nicht drei Wochen, 14 Tage ist es ja.
Infinite Money Glitch.
Ja, einfach seinen eigenen Stream aufmachen und Werbung gucken.
Dass man dann am Ende des Monats 15 Cent bekommt oder so.
Auf Reddit hast du gelesen?
dass ich so wirklich auf red ja gut warum nicht hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
dass reddit sich da reddit irgendwas dazu schreibt
ja gut
Ich bin ein angenehmer Streamer.
Oh, das ist schön, dass ich ein angenehmer Streamer bin.
Das gefällt mir.
Nice.
Ich könnte ein bisschen öfters streamen.
Dann wäre das öfters angenehm.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier Schönes?
Äh, da habe ich keinen Bock.
Was heißt das?
A real robot für 343 Euro.
um was geht es da wo wir es gerade von robotern hatten hugging face beste kann ich auch nur
empfehlen für models da ist man nicht also kann man mit olama kann man die models hier quasi dann
laden direkt von hagen face ohne dass es die bei olama direkt gibt weil die haben irgendwie kaum
noch was im angebot was für ein ding gibt es dann wieder game stütze müsste ich erst einmal
mal ordentlich was spielen, was man streamen kann.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab jetzt einen Roboter auf dem Schreibtisch stehen.
Der heißt Richie Mini, ist komplett open source.
Ich wollte nur kurz gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab jetzt einen Roboter auf dem Schreibtisch stehen.
Der heißt Richie Mini.
Und der wird dann einmal benutzt und nie wieder angefasst, weil eigentlich doch nichts so Tolles bei rumkommt.
Ist komplett Open Source und hat mich inklusive Versand und Steuern 343 Euro gekostet.
Ja, guck mal, Richie erkennt mich und begrüßt mich.
Ich kann Radiosender mit seinen Antennen einstellen.
Ich steuere ihn mit meinem Finger und tanzen kann er auf jeden Fall besser.
Okay, komplett useless, aber je nachdem. Ich meine, es gibt viele useless Sachen, die nicht schlecht sind.
Was soll ich sagen? Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das letzte Mal mit einem Technik-Gadget so viel Spaß hatte.
Und ihr denkt jetzt vielleicht, hä? Testen die bei 3003 jetzt Spielzeug?
Also, würden wir durchaus, ne? Aber Ritchie ist meiner Meinung nach alles andere als ein Spielzeug.
In diesem Video sage ich euch warum und ich zeige euch, was man alles damit machen kann. Bleibt dran!
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internetseufer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Aber was macht man, wenn man gerade Spaß mit seinen Roboterfreunden hat und dann plötzlich der Strom ausfällt?
Dann könnten die Charger und Powerstations von Blue Yeti eine Lösung sein.
Die sponsern nämlich dieses Video.
Glücklicherweise nicht Blue Yeti, Blue Yeti sind nämlich die Mikrofonhersteller.
Unterwegs können die sehr praktisch sein. Der Charger 2 bietet bis zu 1200 Watt Ladeleistung über Fahrzeug und Solarpanels.
Ist das für die ganzen Prepper?
...bis zu 13 mal schneller als ein Standard-Auto-Ladegerät für schnelles und unkompliziertes Laden on the road.
Mit einem Kaffee... ja okay, warum nicht?
Mit einem Charger mit Reverse-Charging gibt es außerdem eine Notfall-Starthilfe, falls die Autobatterie mal leer sein sollte.
Und das Ding liefert einen konstant niedrigen Ladestrom, damit sie gar nicht erst leer geht.
Mit dem Charger 2 lässt sich auch eine One-for-all-Powerstation wie die Apex 300 mit 2764 Wh Kapazität unterwegs schnell aufladen.
Und damit hat man dann quasi Strom überall.
Unterwegs, im Wald oder auch zu Hause, falls mal der Strom ausfällt.
Die Apex 300 Powerstation hat laut Bluetti 40% längere Ausdauer als der Durchschnitt, was hier...
Warum gucken wir uns überhaupt die Werbung an?
...je nach Gerät ungefähr einem Tag extra Laufzeit für einen Kühlschrank entsprechen kann.
Und zusätzlich lässt sie sich mit Akkus noch erweitern.
Mit dem Code BLUETTIE3003 gibt es beim Kauf 5% Rabatt.
Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Werbung Ende.
Ja, Ricci Mini, meinen neuen Roboterfreund, den habe ich lustigerweise in unserem eigenen CT3001 Newsletter entdeckt,
den ich meistens nicht mehr selbst schreibe, sondern das macht mein Kollege Jonathan.
Ey, ey, schreibt er jetzt.
Und der ist in Sachen Robotik und KI offenbar manchmal besser informiert als ich.
Der hat doch einen Mac Mini Cluster am Start.
Schneller auf jeden Fall. Ich habe jedenfalls vorher noch nie von dem Ding gehört und im Newsletter davon gelesen und habe ihn dann sofort bestellt.
Im Juli 2025 war das. Mich hat vor allem das putzige Aussehen überzeugt, aber auch weil ich den Hersteller Pollen Robotics kenne und schätze.
Das ist ein Roboterhersteller aus Frankreich, der kürzlich von Hugging Face gekauft wurde.
Wenn ihr mal was mit Machine Learning oder lokaler KI gemacht habt, kennt ihr die vielleicht.
Da werden zum Beispiel die ganzen KI-Modelle von den lokalen MLMs gehostet.
Naja, ich habe auf jeden Fall auch mal peinlicherweise auf einer Roboterveranstaltung in Frankreich so einen großen Ritchie 2 Roboter von Pollen vielleicht so ein bisschen kaputt gemacht.
War aber wirklich ein Versehen, aber vermutlich war das der Grund, warum die auf meine Anfrage nach einem Testmuster nicht geantwortet haben.
Naja, ich habe den Ritchie Mini dann also ganz normal bezahlt und ganz normal gekauft und das Ding kam jetzt an in einem ziemlich kleinen, aber dafür umso schwereren Paket.
Und da wusste ich auf jeden Fall noch nicht, was da auf mich zukommt, was das Ding so alles kann.
Hat mich echt positiv überrascht, da komme ich gleich aber noch zu.
Was man auf jeden Fall vorher sagen muss, man kann den nur als Bausatz kaufen.
Tatsächlich ist das auch nicht einfach nur ein paar vorbereitete Module.
Das muss schon ein bisschen was gebastelt werden.
Sondern es sind für einen großen Teil wirklich Standardbauteile.
Dass da in dem Handbuch drin steht, dass der Aufbau drei Stunden braucht, das hat mir tatsächlich erst ein bisschen Angst gemacht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, am Ende hat das richtig, richtig Spaß gemacht.
Also wenn ich so überlege, hätte ich direkt nochmal Lust.
Es ist im Prinzip ein bisschen wie advancederes Lego.
Ich kann mir auf jeden Fall, also ich als jemand, der nicht wirklich viel Erfahrung mit Elektronikbasteleien hat, sehr clever vor.
Und das Handbuch, wow, also für so ein Kleinserien-Gadget, extrem gut gemacht und auch schön, dass es das nicht nur als PDF gibt, sondern richtig gedruckt im Karton.
Ich wusste immer genau, was zu tun war. Es wurden auch oft häufige Fehler direkt proaktiv angemerkt bei den Arbeitsschritten, also dass man direkt weiß, da müsste besonders aufpassen.
Man bekommt direkt beim Aufbauen ein richtig gutes Gefühl dafür, wie Roboter funktionieren.
Und ich habe auch direkt was Neues gelernt, nämlich was eine Steward-Plattform ist, also was eigentlich heute Hexapod heißt, mit sechs Motoren, die sich jeweils immer nur in eine Richtung bewegen können.
Und ja, damit wird Richies Kopf bewegt.
So, also jedenfalls alles fertig gebaut.
Und was jetzt?
Ja, ich habe die Lite-Version gekauft.
Die braucht zwingend einen per USB angeschlossenen Computer.
Es gibt auch noch eine Wireless-Variante mit Raspberry 4 und Akku an Bord.
Aber die kostet 150 Euro mehr.
Weil da das Ding eh stationär ist, dachte ich mir, ich habe eh in jedem Raum einen Computer stehen.
Ist egal.
Also auf jeden Fall Rechner dran.
Dann habe ich mir die Desktop-Steuerung runtergeladen.
Die braucht man nicht.
Kann man auch direkt alles über das SDK machen.
Aber so ist es viel komfortabler.
Das Ding heißt auf jeden Fall Ricci Mini Control.
Ist das Windows Only? Ach ne, Mac.
Mac OS und Windows.
Und ja, ich muss sagen, hat mich wirklich direkt beeindruckt, weil das Teil wirklich sehr poliert aussah.
Es hat so eine richtig schöne Science-Fiction-mäßige Startanimation.
Und dann laufen da die ganzen Motor-Check-Ups durch.
Und dann kann man auch direkt so Apps starten.
13 Stück gibt es offiziell vom Hersteller, also heute.
Aber wenn man hier den Haken bei Official wegnimmt, dann sind es, also wenn ich das Video aufnehme.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob man damit auch irgendwas in Anführungszeichen Sinnvolles machen kann oder ob es halt einfach so lustiges Gadget ist.
69 und es werden wirklich täglich mehr zur Zeit.
Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, ganz stumpf technisch.
Was kann der physisch, der Ricci?
Kopfwacke.
Er kann sehen.
Konkret ist da eine Raspberry Pi Kamera V3 eingebaut mit 12 Megapixel Auflösung.
Er kann hören mit einem 4er Mikrofon Array, er kann sprechen oder singen mit einem 5 Watt Soundsystem und bewegungsmäßig kann er auf der Stelle rotieren.
Er kann seinen Kopf über diesen erwähnten Hexapod in alle Richtungen bewegen und er kann die beiden Antennen unabhängig voneinander bewegen.
Die Software kennt tatsächlich immer die Position aller Motoren.
Eigentlich sind das Aktoren, also Smart-Aktoren, konkret Dyna, Mixel, Servo-Motoren.
Und man kann hier in der Desktop-Software auch ganz schön sehen, wenn ich daran rumdrücke und den Roboter bewege, dann verändert sich das Rendering hier in Echtzeit.
Also die Software weiß immer, wo sie sich befindet.
Und das Coole ist, dass man die Motoren auch weich schalten kann, also dass die nachgeben sozusagen.
Und dann lässt sich damit sowas wie Motion Capturing machen.
Ich kann Richie Meanie so marionettenmäßig Bewegungsabläufe beibringen, auch mit Ton.
Ich kann dabei auch Sachen sagen.
Und das Spannende dabei, alleine die Dynamixel Servos, die dabei liegen, würden auf dem freien Markt schon 450 Euro kosten.
Also über 100 Euro mehr, als ich für das ganze Paket bezahlt habe.
Und wenn man sich die Motoren auf freiem Markt kauft, dann ist da natürlich noch kein Gehäuse dabei, keine Kamera, keine Mikrofone.
Also das ist tatsächlich preislich ein wirklich, wirklich gutes Angebot.
Und auch wirklich sehr knapp kalkuliert muss das sein.
Womöglich sogar von Hugging Face subventioniert.
Und die sind ja wegen des völlig von der Realität abgekoppelten KI-Booms ganz gut mit Risikokapital finanziert.
Also wer weiß.
So, aber jetzt natürlich die wichtigste Stelle des Videos, auf die ihr alle hin...
Ich wusste bisher gar nicht, dass Hugging Face so was Größeres dahinter steht.
Fiebert, was kann das Ding Sinnvolles? Wozu ist das überhaupt gut?
Und meine Antwort ist, für nix.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich nicht.
Nee, je nachdem. Ich finde es total sinnvoll, aber es kann erstmal nichts Sinnvolles. Es geht darum, dass ihr und ich lernen können, wie man für Roboter entwickelt und wie man Roboter programmiert.
Okay, da habe ich persönlich kein großes Interesse dran.
Wenn wir echte, große Roboter auch mitbringen, würde ich das so einschätzen, dass sich das wirklich auch extrem gut übertragen lässt.
Pollen hat ja mit Ritchie 2 auch einen großen Roboter mit Armen im Programm und für den lässt sich nahezu genau die gleiche Weise entwickeln wie Ritchie Mini.
Die nutzen auch beide das genau gleiche SDK.
Und jetzt sagt ihr vielleicht, SDK, was ist das eigentlich und kompliziert und Softwareentwicklung.
Ich kann auch nicht wirklich gut programmieren.
Aber wir haben 2026, Vibe-Coding ist das Ding und ich habe da auch überhaupt keine Sicherheit.
Erstmal sein Roboter Vibe-Code.
Roboter, der bei mir einfach auf dem Schreibtisch steht.
Und ich habe das dann einfach mal ausprobiert mit Cloud Code.
Das habe ich benutzt und habe gesagt, hey, ich möchte aus Richie gerne Grüßi machen, den Grüß-Roboter.
Das heißt, er soll irgendwann am Eingang stehen, also weiß ich nicht, im Büro zum Beispiel.
Und dann unterschiedliche Menschen erkennen und je nach Tageszeit mit Namen begrüßen.
Und ganz wichtig, das soll alles lokal passieren.
Ich habe kein Interesse daran, dass das Ding die ganze Zeit einen Videostream irgendwie zu oben AI schickt mit allen Leuten, die da bei mir vorbeikommen.
Vor allem wäre das auch teuer, so über deren Art.
Und es wäre datenschutzmäßig auch bedenklich.
Da sage ich dann auch konkret was zu.
Ja, und dann habe ich Claude Cote einfach einen Link auf die Ricci-Dokumentation gegeben und dann hat er sich das...
Also Opus 4.5 ist schon nice, das muss man echt sagen.
...gezogen und losgelegt.
Und ja, was soll ich sagen, das hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Ich werfe da ein paar Bilder der Leute drauf und wenn die jetzt in den Raum kommen, begrüßt Grüßi die mit Namen und das funktioniert alles lokal.
Guten Abend Kino.
Also ist ein bisschen zeitverzögert, das ist ja in dem Fall gar nicht mal so problematisch.
Ich habe auch so eine Konversations-Laber-App, Vibegecode, die auch lokal läuft, wo dann erst das, was ich sage, über Whisper transkribiert wird, dann an ein lokales LLM geschickt wird und dann die Antwort aus dem Ricci-Lautsprecher über die Sprachsynthese-Bibliothek Piper ausgegeben wird.
Ah, boah, das ist super langsam.
Man muss auch mal nur mit dem Aufnahmeknopf im Browser-Frontend da rumfummeln und naja, ist nicht so richtig cool.
Hey, kannst du was Cooles sagen auf Englisch?
Die offizielle Konversations...
Er hat ein bisschen nach Niederländer angehört.
Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht.
Genau das habe ich auch gedacht.
... die OpenAI-API an, also die sogenannte Real-Time-API.
Und ja, das funktioniert viel besser.
Yo, Richie, altes Haus. Kannst du bitte nur Plattdeutsch mit mir reden?
Klar, ich snack nur Platt mit dir. Was gibt's das für dich?
Kannst du wohl ein bisschen tanzen?
Aber das Ding hat in meinen ungefähr 20 Minuten Nutzung über 5 Euro Kosten angesammelt.
Tja, ist ordentlich.
Das lag auch daran, weil das Richie-Kamera-Bild auch übertragen und ausgewertet wurde.
Also finanziell würde ich sagen, ist das auf Dauer nicht so richtig nachhaltig.
Obwohl es tatsächlich erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Also auch das GPT-5 über dieses MCP-Protokoll, da haben wir ja schon mal ein Video drüber gemacht,
wo die Roboterbewegung steuern kann.
Man kann also einfach so locker sagen, ja, bewegt doch mal den Kopf nach links und zack, macht er das.
Bewegt den Kopf nach links.
Was ich auf jeden Fall sehr interessant fand, alle verfügbaren OpenAI-Stimmen passten null
zu so einem kleinen süßen Roboter.
Hört mal.
Wie de Butter beten, beten wettere Buttenbeter.
Hast de Buttenbeter, wie de Butter beten.
Da konnte ich auf jeden Fall mit meiner lokalen Variante und mit Piper deutlich überzeugendere
Ergebnisse hinkriegen, finde ich.
Ich bin Rikki Mini.
Das stimmt.
Small Expressive Robot from Pollen Robotics.
Es gibt aber außer so, ich will mit meinem Roboter reden, auch wirklich etliche...
Übrigens, diese Standard-Chat-GPT-Stimme triggert mich übelst.
Andere kreative Anwendungen, die ohne Cloud-KI auskommen, zum Beispiel hier,
Ritchie Mini Radio, wo man mit der Antenne unterschiedliche Webradiosender auswählen kann.
Richtig cool ist auch die riesige mitgelieferte Emotionsbibliothek.
Die kann man sich hier zum Beispiel mit der Emotions App angucken und hat dann hier in so Kreisen.
Und da kann man dann so unterschiedliche Emotionen auswählen.
Und ich finde das wirklich ganz überzeugend.
Und natürlich ganz wichtig, tanzen.
Die Software-Plattform, das muss man auch ganz deutlich sagen, die ist noch sehr frisch.
Also heute zum Beispiel ist die Kontrollsoftware dreimal geupdatet worden und hat zwischendurch
auch einfach mal gar nicht funktioniert, was natürlich blöd ist, wenn man da gerade dran
rumbastelt an dem Roboter. Also alles wirklich sehr, sehr work in progress, muss man bedenken.
Aber auch ganz klar ist, Ritchie gehört für mich zu den ausdrucksstärksten Robotern, die ich bislang gesehen habe.
Da kann man richtig mit Persönlichkeit arbeiten.
Was man aber auch noch sagen muss, Ritchie kann halt natürlich nicht woanders hingehen.
Da sind keine Beine oder Räder dran.
Und obwohl er Ritchie heißt, kann er nichts reachen, also nichts greifen.
Aber ey, tut mir einen Gefallen, kommt mir jetzt bitte nicht mit diesem für mich absoluten Anti-Wort Spielerei.
Denn das ist keine Spielerei, denn ich weiß nicht, wie ich auf andere Weise so viel in so kurzer Zeit über die ganz konkrete Nutzung und Entwicklung von modernen Robotern hätte lernen können.
Ja, und auch über Bilderkennung.
Gut, sagen wir mal so, von der Anwendung her ist es schon irgendwie Spielerei.
Ich würde es mal tatsächlich ein bisschen wie Lego sehen, oder sorry, Klemmbausteine.
Interesse haben, ist klar, oder halt eine konkrete Anwendung, die man mit Ricci umsetzen will.
Ist das beides nicht vorhanden, dann braucht man Ricci natürlich nicht.
Und also als reines Deko-Objekt sind 343 Euro natürlich auch viel zu viel.
Interessiert ihr euch aber für Roboter und sind beim Gucken dieses Videos bei euch direkt tausend Ideen rausgesprudelt,
was man mit dem lustigen Gesellkarten anstellen kann, dann kann ich euch Ricci Mini wirklich doll ans Herz legen.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass die Community da gerade sehr aktiv wird und da gerade sehr viele interessante Sachen entstehen. Also ich bleibe da auf jeden Fall dran. Schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, was ihr damit machen würdet. Interessiert mich wirklich sehr. Ich werde da sicherlich auch noch etwas mehr in unserem Podcast CT4004 drüber reden. Wenn euch das interessiert, gerne reinhören. Tschüss.
So, auf dem Panel, wo ich die Höhe von 10.000 und die Höhe von einer anderen Plane
Diese Stimme hier.
Das trinkt an mich so hart, wenn ich diese Chat-GPT-Stimme höre.
Die klingt immer so, so ey, Alter, ich weiß voll, um was es geht und labert den größten Scheiß.
Weil ich diese Stimme mit
Chat-GPT
dumm gelabert
verbinde.
Wer Bock hat, kann sich das Video angucken.
Das ist so
sinnbildlich für viele Sachen, wie es da läuft.
Die AI
ist halt richtig gut da drin.
Massen an Wörtern zu generieren, die erstmal sinnvoll klingen, aber halt nichts aussagen in der Situation.
Ihr müsst euch das Video mal angucken bei Gelegenheit, so könnt ihr durchscrollen. Chat-GPT gibt nichts Sinnvolles von sich und tut immer so, als wäre das ganz easy.
Hier einfach mal ein bisschen das Flugzeug rumdrehen und dann sieht man schon die Landebahn, easy, ja und du machst das gut.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Das gucken wir nicht.
Was macht eigentlich schon lange nichts mehr geguckt?
Was macht eigentlich der Auer?
Der Achtauer, der Bauer.
Gibt es da irgendwas Spannendes, Neues?
Ah, nix.
Moment.
das Stromkabel
ist immer noch kacke
nach über
5 Jahren oder so
seitdem dieses Stromkabel gibt
ist das immer noch Schrott
geil
ich hab das ja extra ausgetauscht
bei mir
gegen eins was direkt ans Netzteil drankommt
und nicht so einen komischen Zwischenstecker hat
Ja, seitdem ich nicht mehr so oft streame und den Browser hier aufmache, kriege ich ganz komische Empfehlungen.
Everybody hates the new Microsoft Office.
Okay, das muss ich mir kurz angucken.
Das stimmt wohl.
und vor allem, was die Leute
wieder wahnsinnig irritiert hat, dass ja
Microsoft angeblich
Office umbenannt hat.
Also erstes Mal wurde Office umbenannt
in Microsoft 365.
Office 365 hieß das ja gar nicht mehr.
Und jetzt in Copilot App.
Wobei es dann wiederum rauskam,
das stimmt nicht so ganz. Aber die Meldung
war eindeutig
Chat-GPT generiert, weil die war so dumm
geschrieben, dass man eindeutig daraus lesen konnte,
Office bzw. Microsoft 365
365 wurde in Co-Pilot App umbenannt.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Erklärung dafür, warum Microsoft so einen Shit macht.
Oh nein! Oh nein!
Erinnern die euch noch?
Moment.
Erinnern die euch noch an das?
Das war so
schmerzhaft dazu zu gucken.
Die haben so...
Die Windows 11 Präsentation, die war so schlimm.
Die war so
ultra emotional gemacht.
Die haben die ganze Zeit auch so geredet, als passiert jetzt gerade irgendwie sowas, so, so, so, boah, keine Ahnung, wie kann man das, da fällt mir gar kein Vergleich dazu ein. Sowas super emotionales, ja.
Ja, stellt euch vor, okay, machen wir mal sowas.
Ja, stellt euch vor, ich gehe jetzt mal von mir aus, ja.
Keine Ahnung, meine Oma und mein Opa leben ja nicht mehr.
Stellt euch vor, ich würde jetzt ein altes Fotoalbum oder so finden,
wo ich ein paar Sachen sehe von Oma und Opa, was ich noch nicht kenne.
Oder ist mal so ein bisschen emotional und sagt, ach ja, guck mal, so wie sie.
So diese Stimmung, so diese Stimmung haben die versucht,
bei der Windows 11 Präsentation zu machen.
und die haben halb geflankt dabei, Alter.
Ihr müsst euch nur den Anfang angucken.
Wir gucken nur den Anfang.
Nur den Anfang.
Das gibt's gar nicht mehr, oder was?
Ja.
Das hier.
Der hat halb geweint.
Hörst du das? Der ist halb am Flennen.
Der weint fast, als er Windows präsentiert, Alter.
Jetzt kommen wir hier und zeigen sie noch alte Fotos und sowas.
in the past, especially in product making.
And when you think about it,
Windows has been part of our lives for
35 years.
30?
35 years. It's been a driving
force for innovation.
It's been a platform
for creation. It's been home
to billions.
To help us do our jobs, live our dreams
and connect with people we love.
And for me,
for me, as I
Das ist doch grausam, oder?
Diese Präsentation, Alter.
WTF?
The fuck?
Jetzt gibt es ja noch irgendwelche Fotos aus der Kindheit.
Das ist, ja das ist das Windows 11 Event gewesen.
Das ist so schlimm.
Ihr kennt das anscheinend noch nicht.
Ihr seid froh, dass ihr das nicht geguckt habt.
Ganz grausam.
Ganz grausam, Alter.
Muss ich mal zumachen, sonst mach ich das noch aus Versehen wieder an.
Ja.
AI.
Und das ...
Guck, formerly Office.
Oh, das wird überhaupt nicht umbenannt.
Aber die Ankündigung war so dumm,
dass man das halt eindeutig rausgelesen hat.
hat 366 da ist barbara von barth in macs next thing people don't like was the over cramming
of a in dieser wehr des a in the toolbar every time you're right click and das passt wie gesagt
der microsoft-chef hat letztens wohl angeblich eine runde geschrieben an seine employees hat
gesagt wer keinen bock auf er hat soll abhauen everywhere you curse ago's beseitigt es ist
Ja und? Und hat er nicht letztens irgendwas erzählt, dass die Leute es nicht AI-Slob nennen
sollen, weil das so disrespectful wäre gegenüber den Leuten, die an AI entwickeln oder irgendwie
sowas? Und seitdem sagt ja jeder nur noch Micro-Slob. Hat er sich selbst was eingebrockt.
Und die CEO hat to step in and tell people to stop calling it AI-Slob.
Ach, stimmt, da haben wir's doch schon.
... what you're paying us $10 a month for.
And please keep doing that,
as AI has been a roaring success in our software.
Like the Co-Pilot Voice Assistant,
that you get a couple minutes for free,
then you gotta pay for that call, baby.
Talk about a premium phone line.
And it sounds amazing, it feels amazing,
and I get excited, I love it.
Alter, wie der war zweit schon wieder.
oder die ai in settings das theater help unless your question is really simple then it has no
idea or who could forget windows recall stimmt stimmt wie sieht es damit jetzt eigentlich aus
okay in der eu gibt es ja nicht aber das heißt jetzt die fault dass windows alle paar sekunden
die konnten Screenshots macht.
365, 1.800, Co-Pilot, 3 Dollar a minute, Premium, Sexline.
We need the money.
Ah, we certainly don't need the money, but we want it.
The all new MicroSlop 365.
If you thought we made bad products before, you ain't seen nothing yet.
Subscribe today.
Ich muss auch mal sagen, die Xbox 360, auch wenn man es hier sieht,
die war mit, meiner Meinung nach, mit das Beste, was Microsoft dir auf die Reihe gebracht hat.
Und auch mit allem drum und dran.
Das hat ja, man muss mal ehrlich sagen, im Konsolenbereich hat die Xbox 360 Online Gaming eigentlich so richtig Mainstream gemacht.
Gab es vorher nicht auf der Konsole in dem Fall.
Und da war Xbox Live vorne mit dabei.
Da wurde ich ja immer geflamed für, dass ich gesagt habe, Xbox Live ist so viel besser als das PSN damals auf der PS3.
Ja, es hat was gekostet, das PSN war kostenlos, okay.
aber das hat den playstation leuten nicht so gut gefallen damals immer
man hätte ja auch das original den originalen browser aufführen können
er hat auch nicht so lange gemacht
macht.
Erinnert sich noch einer an Original Edge,
der noch nicht Chrome
basiert war?
Windows
Then vs. Now.
Okay, komm.
Ich habe jetzt schon ein bisschen über Microsoft geraged.
Wir machen jetzt, wir ragen noch ein bisschen weiter über Microsoft.
Es gab noch ein Chrome Edge, ja, ja.
Was? Edge kann kein 4K-Playback?
Das geht doch sogar auf YouTube.
Wegen DRM. Okay.
Ja, ja.
Was ist eigentlich? Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Vielleicht wisst ihr das.
Was ist denn eigentlich aus dieser
Geschichte geworden?
Google möchte Sideloading auf
Android abschalten.
Ist das, kommt das jetzt? Oder haben die zurückgerudert? Oder wie ist das?
Ist ja das, weil ganz ehrlich, für mich war Sideloading und die ganzen, sagen wir so, Customization und Eingriffe, die man in Android machen konnte, der Pluspunkt von Android.
Deswegen sind meine Smart Home Tablets hier an der Wand im Flur auch Android, weil man damit viel mehr machen konnte.
Ansonsten im Alltag benutze ich ein iPhone und ein iPad.
Kommt bestimmt, die machen das bestimmt wie bei, wie hieß das Ding, Manifest V3.
Ein paar mal rückziehe und irgendwann ist es dann da.
Ja, ist es.
Wir können es gegen Vista
kompären. Vista wurde ja überhaupt
nicht gemacht, als es draußen ist.
Aber Vista sah auch noch halbwegs aus einem
Guss aus.
Das ist heute immer noch so.
Also was du bei Vista definitiv nicht machen musst, ist jetzt erstmal 80 mal auf nein, nein, nein, minimal, nein, nein, nein, nicht share, nein, nein, minimal drücken.
die neuesten macOS versucht zu erstellen.
I'm so excited to use this.
I've never actually used Windows Vista.
I jumped from Windows XP to Windows 7.
Oh, the mouse cursor changed.
Now it's the Aereo cursor.
Although nowadays it doesn't have like the subtle shadow.
Lost its je ne sais quoi.
Oh yes, the pictures.
Of course I have to do the fish.
Foosh.
Choose a desktop background.
You can make changes later in the control panel.
Of course we have to go with the classic one.
This is such a nice experience of setting Windows up.
Instead of having to constantly click,
Ja, genau.
Okay, so they still used to do it.
And boom, there's my user account.
Okay, 10 times, if not 100 times better
than the Windows 11 Setup Experience.
They forced the Microsoft
account down your throat now.
Ist das AI?
Mittlerweile kannst du dir gar nicht sicher sein,
ob das, wenn du sowas siehst, ob das nicht doch AI ist.
Die wurden abgeschaltet.
wieder das wurde damals richtig krass gehypt jetzt war series liebe benutzt irgend ich habe
sogar schon ausgeblendet benutzt irgend jemand dieses komische windows 11 widgets feature ich
kenne niemand niemand also das benutzt einfach keiner
das startmenü mit let's test out windows search if i place a folder somewhere what is this show
desktop switch between windows how do i go to like my computer okay was gut zu dokumenten
I can't see my C drive or anything.
Okay, never mind.
There's folders down here.
And I can see computer.
Wait, it's crazy how little this has changed.
So what if I create a folder and then let's go inside of here.
Was sie gechanged haben, was sie gechanged haben ist,
dass wenn man jetzt einen Ordner anklickt, dieses Menü kommt.
Und wenn du wirklich was damit machen willst, musst du auf Schau...
Also wer das bei Microsoft abgesegnet hat, das ist so unglaublich dämlich.
Jetzt kommen wir in das alte Menü.
Äh.
Nein, nein, es gibt jetzt was Neues.
Es gibt jetzt neue Widgets.
Hier.
Oh, Mann.
Widgets in Windows 11 is a great way to view all your favorite content from right there within your desktop.
Guck mal, das ist so geil.
Mein Browser ist gecrashed.
Leute, beim Abspielen.
Hier Widgets.
Da hast du es hier.
Guck, dieses hässliche Ding.
Alter, YouTube, Mann.
Jetzt mach hin.
Er hat keinen Bock.
Das ist bestimmt wegen meinem Adblocker.
Hey, hey.
Ja, okay, Moment.
Genau, da unten gibt es einen Knopf.
Das Ding meine ich hier.
Das Ding.
Das habe ich ausgeblendet, weil ich es nicht benutze.
Keine Sau, die ich kenne.
Niemand.
Niemand verwendet das.
Das habe ich gemeint.
Ja, und man konnte damals auch noch Sachen gescheit schräg und trocken im Startmenü.
Mauspointers. No way, there's dinosaur.
No way, there's dinosaur. Alter!
There's banana. This used to ship
with Windows. The dinosaur...
Das brauche ich.
Ich brauche den Dinosaurier.
Als Mauszeiger.
System Scheme Cursor. I've never seen this.
When it's working in background, it's a blue
walking dinosaur. Why is this not a thing
in Windows 11? Wait, Conductor?
Hohohoho.
I never knew this was a thing.
Look at that text cursor. It's just a hand
holding the text select.
Wait, it used to be so much more fun.
3D White.
It's the default, but 3D.
3D Bronze.
Busy, it has a timer.
Old-fashioned.
Kennt noch einer die Skins für den alten Windows Media Player?
So diese Alien-Kopf und sowas?
War schon abgetreter, das Zeug früher.
There's a horse running.
When it's busy, there's this thing spinning.
What is that?
When it's unavailable, it just flops the ending.
Wait, it's filling up.
Why?
I mean, why not?
Okay, I'm using the dinosaur cursor 100%.
What if I go into Theme?
windows vista windows classic oh yeah oh yeah that's windows classic screensaver
let's check there's the dinosaur did you see that it was used to be so much more
fun look at this surely okay und schön sieht's nett aus muss man aber auch ehrlich sagen jetzt
ne it's on windows 11 right or can you i just don't know because it's buried among a billion
telemetry settings okay is there multitasking inside of windows vista does alt tab work yes
it does it doesn't show previews though are there virtual desktops though i know
Ja, Tom in Pixels ist leider so, wie Leute waren damals auch planlos.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich brauche diesen Kursor auf Windows 11.
Die alte, coole Farbe, Damen und Herren.
Warte, wenn du ein Fenster drückst, wird es nicht maximalisiert.
Sicherlich macht es das, oder?
Nein, das gab es damals noch nicht.
Ich habe das so viel als Kind gemacht.
Just pick this airbrush tool, set it to highest and create fireworks.
Warte, nein, nein, nein.
Das war ein Rookie-Mistakel.
You always fill it with black to begin with, because fireworks happen at night, obviously.
And then you just firework away.
I'm having way too much fun than I should.
At the end, you just pick black and, you know, make it so not everywhere are fireworks.
Perfect.
You know what?
I'm saving this image.
I don't know how to find settings.
I found personalize.
Like, how do I change my screen resolution?
Oh, display settings.
There's no way it does 4K.
It does do 4K?
What is their display scaling, though?
This is 4K Windows Vista.
Oh wait, adjust font size DPI.
Large scale, M, space, ache, text more readable.
You must restart your computer to apply these changes.
Okay, let's do it.
No way, this is so...
Okay, damals muss man tatsächlich noch deutlich mehr restarten, das stimmt.
Cool.
It's also very similar to Windows 7.
I used to search up for the Windows Vista wallpaper back when I used Windows 7.
And I remember my desktop looking very similar.
Do I have bigger display scaling now?
Oh, scale to this percentage of normal size.
So let's do 150%.
Actually, it does exist.
You must restart your computer every time.
That's definitely better on Windows 11.
Okay, yeah, everything got bigger, I think.
Windows Mail.
Looks like a folder icon.
They took this icon from Windows Mail and used it as the Explorer icon, didn't they?
Windows Media Center.
Windows Media Center war ganz gut für die Zeit damals.
Hatte damals auch so ein Mini-PC im Wohnzimmer stehen mit Windows Media Center drauf.
Aber danach hatte ich Media Portal.
... for digital and on-demand media.
What's the difference between a Windows Media Player and Media Center?
Wie der Sender ist Fullscreen.
Und du kannst damit Fernsehen gucken und so.
Windows Big Picture, like Steam Big Picture.
Minesweeper.
Boom.
There's one around this one, so this is for sure a bomb.
And this is for sure not a bomb.
So this is also...
Wait.
This is not a bomb.
Since this says to, it has to be here.
Since this is to, it can't be here.
Since this says to, it can't be here.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt wissen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie Mind Sweeper funktioniert.
Ich weiß nur, dass es Weltmeisterschaften in Mind Sweeper gibt.
Wo immer das herkommt.
Also schauen wir uns den Task Manager an und dann die Leistung.
Wie viel benutzt es, wenn ich nichts mache?
0-4% der CPU und 900 MB RAM.
Es wird interessant sein, was wir auf Windows 11 sehen.
Wir haben noch das klassische Windows 7 Menü und den alten Mauskursor,
auch wenn das Windows 11 ist.
Oh nein, jetzt wird es eklig.
Ein paar Details.
Bereit, zu installieren.
Los geht's.
Nachdem das fertig war, war ich schon in Windows Vista.
Es hat mich gefragt, ein Passwort und ein Wallpaper zu wählen.
Das ist es.
Let's see what happens here.
And there it is.
Let's connect you to a network.
Lokale Accounts, nur noch mit Windows Pro.
Need an internet connection to continue setting up your device.
And there's no way to say no.
You have to connect to the internet.
It's like the technology aged.
You used to be able to do it without internet.
And then for a new revolutionary operating system.
Dass sie dir noch eine AI-Kram verkaufen können.
You have to have internet connection.
I mean, I will show you a workaround, of course.
You press Shift F 10, which opens this thing.
And then you have to type O O B E, which Microsoft will soon disable, I believe.
Mittlerweile ist das auch disabled für Windows Home, oder?
Für Windows 11 Home, das geht, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Slash, bypass and R O.
Boom, never mind.
I think you don't need the space here.
Boom.
It says, just a moment, it will restart.
And then magically, out of nowhere, I will be able to click.
Hm, I don't have internet connection.
Oh, look at that.
I don't have internet.
How convenient.
Most people will never know that they need to press Shift-F10 for this scary black window to open up, let alone paste some weird commands in there.
Let's proceed to do this installation as an average regular human would.
Well, this has just been black screened for the last 5 minutes.
Checking for Windows updates now, still going on 20 minutes later.
I mean, Windows Vista wasn't connected to the Internet, so I can't compare, but this is just spinning.
Oh, just as I said that. Your update is in progress. We'll take it from here. Never mind.
Okay, finally something's happening. 30 minutes later. I'm 90% there.
Ja, jetzt kommt ja noch das Schlimmste. Jetzt musst du gleich noch auswählen, dass du nicht getrackt werden willst und sowas.
Und dann geht das manchmal nicht. Ich kann sagen, nur minimal.
Now. Are we in the desktop? I haven't picked my password yet. So how welcome are we really?
Jetzt kommt der ganze Mist.
Unlock your Microsoft Experience. Sign in. There's no other option.
Let's do a little temporary email strategy.
please i'm not a robot yeah maybe this is a bicycle yeah yeah thinking verify it always
works when i do that what is your name shoe person solve a puzzle so we know you're not a robot
windows use the arrow keys to capture the windows installer vtf object to face in the direction of
the hand okay that looks like the same direction the windows vist installation took like what five
minutes this is already taking 45 and i'm not even close choose privacy settings for your device
location find my device diagnostic data you know what accept just gave out all of my information
So, ich bin wieder da.
Alter, was ein Abfuck!
Das ist mir, das, also in der, in der Ausprägung hatte ich das noch nie.
Ich klicke immer alles. No, no, no, no, no.
Local account, no, no.
Aber wenn du aus Pro geht, das ja noch.
Text messages, make calls and more, all from your PC.
Okay, this is good. This is cool.
When you browse the web using Microsoft Edge,
will bring your browsing data such as favorites, browsing history, cookies
and more into Microsoft Edge from your other browser.
Wait, so wait, are they asking to access my browsing history from other browsers
and just yoink it into Edge whenever they want?
Okay, I'm too scared to allow this.
Wait, is that legal?
Oh, I'm in luck. You've landed a free trial. A one month free trial, then 99 per year.
Okay, nice. How many of these like advertisement screens will I see?
Get more cloud storage. Can I get past all of the Microsoft ads and into my operating system?
Das ist schon krasser Abfuck, oder?
Microsoft 365 for free. So I didn't pay. Now they're offering it for free.
Join Game Pass Premium for only 1499.
Alter, das hört ja gar nicht auf.
I have to decline like three subscriptions to get into Windows.
Das lädt alles noch nach.
Die Falsch.
Ja, das sehe ich auch kritisch.
Und wenn er jetzt Edge zuklickt, will sich gleich irgendeine App pinnen unten.
Geht auch nicht.
Browse alongside your AI companion.
Also it's like AI integration inside of the browser.
Boom!
Was macht man eigentlich, wenn man diesen ganzen Scheiß nicht will?
Ausschalten geht ja nicht mehr.
Homescreen.
I wasn't able to see the homescreen on Windows Vista.
Aber mit lokalem Account hat man deutlich weniger von dem Kram.
On the Internet Explorer, because I had no Internet.
Surely it can't be worse than this.
Especially when I'm used to browsers on my actual Windows
looking super clean like this.
Just a search bar.
Compare this.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich habe das Ganze in meiner Location verwendet. Microsoft Edge. Warum? Es ist nicht auf. Viele Leute verwenden Windows so.
Sie installieren es einfach und lassen es als Default. Was ich beobachten wollte, ist, dass ich in den Task Manager gehe und sehe, wie viele Ressourcen es verwendet.
Nur auf Idle. 38% Erinnerung. Ich glaube, es war 11% auf Windows Vista. Ich habe einfach dieses Computer wieder aufgebaut.
Ich habe nichts anderes gemacht, außer den Task Manager geöffnet. 38% meiner Erinnerung.
Da läuft schon ein bisschen was im Hintergrund, ne? Auch wenn nichts passiert.
Oha!
Das ist ja schrecklich!
Content will be available the next time you open.
Yeah, this is also very good.
If I type something and then close Notepad,
the next time that I open it, it will remember what I put there.
You have to agree, this is objectively good.
There is a co-pilot button here.
Is it just me or when Microsoft adds some new button,
I never click it.
Because my expectations are that it will ask me to subscribe
or sign up for some service.
And the expectations are true.
Yeah, subscription required.
They add an actual useful feature
that you don't want to just run away from
or turn off so rarely that every new button that appears i just want to stay away from it obviously
it has much better features and a huge market share almost all apps and games that you want
to run work on windows but microsoft just keeps shooting themselves in the foot by tracking
everything that you do on your computer settings
computer and placing ads and news everywhere you go like why would i need to see
get ready for halloween inside of my search windows vista seemed like more fun there were
cool dinosaur mouse cursors and microsoft could just choose to not do this they could choose to
not show all of their possible subscription services when you're just trying to install
the operating system yeah da sieht man halt dass windows keine priorität mehr ist von microsoft
sie sind alles nur noch cloud und ai
Das sieht nicht so an, wie es sich anwenden würde.
Wir sammeln die notwendigen Daten, um OneDrive und Microsoft 365 sicher zu machen.
Sie versuchen so hart, um dir...
Oh, by the way, this context menu, show more options.
Das ist das Schlimmste.
Why did they do this?
This was perfectly fine.
You can just right-click, boom, refresh.
I think on my actual main windows I have this set.
Yeah, I have this old one by default.
Das geht?
Das brauche ich auch.
Things from here, then you can from here.
Muss ich gar nicht, dass das geht?
Like the same size.
So yeah, this is what I wanted to explore.
Let me know what you think.
Ja, Schrott ist es, das denke ich.
Äh, ja.
Das geht über Registry Changes.
Natürlich, für die wichtigen Sachen gibt es keine Settings im Settings-Menü.
Ja, klar.
Logisch.
So, Chatge.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Übelst Hunger.
Nudels.
Aber ohne Lachs.
Nudels mit Hähnchen
und vielleicht
Chat
das hat mir sehr, fand ich sehr nice
den Stream, mir geht es jetzt deutlich besser
als noch gestern zum Beispiel
hilft immer ein bisschen
was sich im Kopf abzulenken
vielleicht machen wir dann
heute Mittag einfach weiter und bauen mal
PXE
Boot auf
und ich rage, dass PXE
sowas abartiges ist.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich mach das aber nicht ganz
blind, ich hab schon ein bisschen gebastelt.
Ja, schön.
Ja gut, da muss ich ja heute Mittag ran, ne?
Okay, alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns dann. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.
Achso, und wenn dem Stream gefallen hat,
der kann gerne followen jetzt an der Stelle.
Dann sehen wir uns später. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.